Herzlich Willkommen zur Alternativlos Folge Nr. 25. Heute geht es um digitale Kriege, digitale Waffen, Volgo, Cyberwar und als Gast haben wir heute Fx im Studio. Guten Abend.
Tag auch.
Und das Thema haben wir uns natürlich aus wie immer aktuellem Anlass herangenommen, nachdem die Presse immer voll ist mit diesem Cyberwar, irgendwie wir werden alle sterben, digitales Pearl Harbor und die Bundeswehr macht jetzt auch die Bundeswehr macht jetzt auch ein Cyberwar. Da dachten wir uns, da müssen wir uns das Thema doch mal annehmen und vor allen Dingen uns jemanden dazu einladen, der sich tatsächlich auf diese ganzen merkwürdigen Konferenzen traut und mit diesen Leuten auch noch redet, wo andere Leute das ja schon nicht mehr tun.
Vor allem haben wir jetzt auch jemanden, der zugegeben hat, dass er schuld ist, nämlich die Amis und Israelis, das ist aber noch nicht ganz klar, weil erst haben es die Amis zugegeben für sich selbst. Und dann haben sie gesagt, es geht um Stuxnet und Flam. Erst haben die Amis zugegeben, dass sie es sind, dann haben die Amis zugegeben, dass sie mit den Israelis waren und dann hat man so gehört, dass die Israelis eigentlich unzufrieden damit waren, dass die Amis sich überhaupt genannt haben. Aber man weiß wie immer nichts, aber man weiß immerhin, dass ein paar Leute bereit sind, Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Das heißt, wir sind jetzt aus der Theoriephase raus, wir sind jetzt in der Faktenphase.
Da kommen wir dann später nochmal dazu, welche möglichen strategischen Implikationen diese oder Hintergründe dieses zugeben hat. Aber lass uns mal mit Definitionen anfangen. Was ist denn eigentlich jetzt diese Cyberwar?
Ja, das ist ja gar nicht so einfach. Also ich habe hier mal so ein paar Definitionen rausgesucht. Spannend ist dabei irgendwie das Krieg an sich. Nach der sicherheitspolitischen Glossade Bundesministerium für politische Bildung versteht man unter Krieg ein mittels systematischer Gewaltanwendung ausgetragener auseinandersetzung zwischen zwei oder mehr organisierten Gruppen. Eins davon ist per Definition ein Staat. Also Krieg kannst du nur führen, wenn du mindestens einen Staat dabei hast. Wann es denn so richtig ein Krieg ist, ist nicht so richtig klar. Da gibt es verschiedene Definitionen. Witzigerweise die meisten machen das an der Menge der Todesopfer fest. Also zum Beispiel das Peace Research Institute in Oslo sagt, bis 999 Todesopfer ist es ein Konflikt und dann redest du vor dem Krieg.
Ist ja super.
Ist immerhin mal eine handliche Definition so.
Na ja, früher hat man Kriege noch angesagt. aus der Zeit sind wir jetzt voraus. Wie ist denn das, wenn jetzt wie in Afghanistan mehr Leute an Selbstmord sterben als an Kampfhandlungen?
Ich vermute, die zählst du einfach mit. Ja, aber das ist schon richtig. Also es gibt keine Kriegserklärung. Es geht nicht mehr, sondern seit der UN-Karta entscheidet das der Sicherheitsrat. Also der Sicherheitsrat sagt, ab wann ein genügend großer Threat, die das zur Verfügung steht, und dann wird halt gesagt, so jetzt machen wir Krieg.
Interessant daran, dass der Grund, warum Kriege nicht mehr erklärt werden, und dann erreglicht es eben daran, dass in den meisten Demokratien Kriege unter Parlamentsvorbehalt fallen. Das heißt also, dass die Institution, die in der Demokratie den Krieg tatsächlich erklärt, also sagt jetzt erst mal hier Krieg, ist das Parlament. Und so ein Parlament hat da in der Regel nicht so viel lust drauf, oder wenn, dann doch irgendwie erheblichen Redebedarf.
Na und vor allem, wenn dann die Bevölkerung unzufrieden ist und eine Kampagne macht, dann lassen die sich umstimmen. Und das geht ja nicht, wenn man schon geplant hat.
Genau. Und dann muss man auch noch sehen, dass natürlich der größte Teil der meditärischen auseinandersetzung, der Neuzeit, also nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, also eigentlich nach dem Vietnamkrieg, ja primär eben keine erklärten großen Kriege waren, sondern halt so Special Forces-Operationen und ähnliche Dinge, die halt so unter dem Radar stattfinden sollten, bestreitbar waren, plausible deniability aufweisen.
Das ist auch der Hauptvorteil von Cyberwar.
Genau. Und was sozusagen der interessante Parallele ist, dass ja also gerade diese Verborgenheit und dieses Nicht-in-der-Öffentlichkeit-Stadt-Finden von eben diesen militärischen Operationen, die eben nicht als Krieg deklariert werden, sich ja dann eben eins zu eins eben in diesem Digitalfeld wiederfindet.
Naja, die Sache ist halt durchaus, dass diese ganzen internationalen Rechtsfragen sich halt ändern, ob man gerade einen Armtkonflikt, also eine kriegerische Handlung hat oder nicht. Deswegen Cyberwar kann es eigentlich nur geben, wenn man überhaupt gerade schon eine kriegerische Handlung am Hals hat. Also der Florian Grunert hat eine schöne Dreistufendefinition von Cyberwar gebaut, wo er sagt, zuerstens ist es einfach erst mal die ausnutzung von Sicherheitslücken in irgendwelchen vernetzten Technologien, dann ist es eine eigene Domäne und es ist die Gesamtheit aller Cyberangriffe für Zerstörung, Spionage, Manipulation während einer kriegerischen Handlung. Deswegen reden die Leute so in den letzten zwei Jahren auch mehr von Cyberconflikt als von Cyberwar, weil Krieg halt völkerrechtlich klar definiert ist.
Verstehe, und Cyberconflikt ist dann halt irgendwie mehr so diese Guerrilla-Operation?
Alles andere.
Das hatten wir auch schon in der Sendung hier, dass dann plötzlich Regeln gelten, dass man keine krankenhäuser angreifen darf und so, wenn man im Krieg ist. Und combatantenstatus versus zivilistenstatus und so.
Jaja.
Also das spielt auch im Internet eine Rolle.
Na gut, ich meine, über die Frage des combatantenstatus in digital geführten auseinandersetzungen.
Na, das ist wichtig, wenn dich jemand...
Will man eigentlich, glaube ich, nicht so richtig nachdenken.
Na doch. Doch, doch. Das ist einer der, das ist der Kernprobleme, wenn, wenn, sagen wir mal, jetzt gibt es einen Krieg zwischen, sagen wir, Amerika und was weiß ich, irgendwie Irak, sagen wir mal, oder Iran, nehmen wir mal aus, greifen wir mal in die Kristallkugel. Und da wird irgendein Wurm losgetreten und der betrifft dann auch irgendwie die Privatcomputer von irgendwelchen Bürgern. Das wäre dann ein Kriegsverbrechen, ne?
Ja, das wären Verbrechen gegen die vierte Genfer Konvention. Und zwar gegen die Punkte, dass wie heißt es so schön? The parties to conflict and members of the armed forces do not have unlimited choice of methods and means of warfare. Das heißt, man kann sich eigentlich als Kriegsführende Partei erstmal nicht so beliebig aussuchen, was man da macht. Weswegen diese ganze Cyberwar-Geschichte schon sehr grau ist. Und dann the parties to a conflict shall at all times distinguish between a civilian population and combatants. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt ein krankenhaus mit infiziere, dann habe ich schon mal die Genfer Konvention verletzt.
Viel interessanter als krankenhäuser finde ich hier solche Sachen wie Infrastrukturen. Also was passiert, wenn man halt tatsächlich mal auf digitalem Wege so ein Stromnetz runterfährt als Akt eines digitalen Angriffs? Dann wird ja eigentlich schon ein Verstoß gegen die Genfer Konvention, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Man soll, also man muss halt sehr aufpassen. Wie geht es hier weiter? Neither this civilian population as such nor civilian persons shall be the object of attack. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie Zivilisten mit erwische, dann habe ich da schon mal Mist gebaut.
Na gut, aber man kann jetzt argumentieren, so ein Atombomber auf Hiroshima hat ja auch Zivilisten getroffen, nicht nur.
Das war ja auch ein Kriegsverbrechen. Also dann muss man...
Nein, aber ich meine, das kannst du auch bei allen anderen Raketen behaupten. Also das einfach sagen, wenn du jetzt irgendwie mit einer Drohne in ein Dorf in Afghanistan plattaust, dann behaupten sie ja auch einfach danach, es sind alles Kombatanten gewesen.
Nein, das behaupten sie eben nicht ohne Grund, damit sie eben sagen können, sie haben sich halt irgendwie daran gehalten.
Wenn wir das in Zukunft dann auch im Internet sehen, dass man sagt einfach, naja, das waren auch Kombatanten, weil sie ja im Internet waren.
Du meinst, wenn sozusagen ein Gebiet des Internets zur Zone of Armed Conflict deklariert wird?
Wenn die Routing-Tabelle dann plötzlich entscheidet, ob du ein Kombatant bist oder nicht?
Führen wir einfach eine neue BGP-Community ein und fertig.
Hier ist Frieden, genau. Okay, also wir sehen halt, die Definition sagt eigentlich relativ eindeutig, dass man ja keine kriegischen auseinandersetzungen im digitalen Feld führen sollte. Schon lange entlendet, deswegen, weil man irgendwie nicht mal genau definieren kann, wo hört denn da der Frieden auf und wo fängt denn der Krieg an? Und wo ist jetzt eigentlich der Unterschied zum Beispiel zu Spionage, Geheimdienstoperationen, Sabotage? Also das ist ja ein enormes Graufeld. Und wenn wir jetzt mal eines der Posterbeispiele der letzten Zeit nehmen, also Schluxnet, die ja relativ gut untersucht ist, wo noch eher relativ klar ist, was das Ziel war und wer irgendwie die Angreifer waren und wer das Opfer war, dann zeigt sich ja da, dass es ja eigentlich benutzt wurde als Ersatz für eine kinetische militärische Operation, also eben für einen Angriff mit Raketen oder Bomben. So und die spannende Frage dabei ist natürlich, führt es dazu, dass die Grauzone zwischen Krieg und Frieden noch grauer wird, weil natürlich, vor digitaler Zeit hätten sie da im Zweifel ein paar Special Forces-Helden hingeschickt als Sabotage-Team oder?
Na der Präsidentsfall ist ein Luftangriff. Israel hat ja mal so ein Atomkraftwerk, der im Irak weg ist, das ist so der bekannteste Fall, da haben sie halt.
Und in Syrien auch.
Ja in Syrien, da war es aber noch nicht fertig. Im Irak war sozusagen Schlüssel fertig, wenn ich das recht nenne. Das ist korrekt, ja. Also Special Forces erzählt man immer so, aber das ist ja wohl nicht so einfach. Gut, da sind jetzt auch im Iran einige Leute unter mysteriösen Umständen verloren gegangen. aus der Atom-Community insofern machen sie das wohl auch. Aber ja, die Frage stellt sich, was machen wir denn jetzt in Zukunft? Müssen wir jetzt damit rechnen, angegriffen zu werden von irgendwelchen Aktionen? Und da ist es vielleicht ganz hilfreich, wenn wir uns mal angucken, was es so historisch für Sachen gab. Stuxnet ist eine Sache. Was gab es noch?
Historisch gab es eine Zeit lang so ein paar einzelne Beispiele, die so aussahen, als könnte es so was gewesen sein. So eines der berühmteren ist die Explosion von so einer russischen Gaspipeline, wo sich relativ hartnäckig die Geschichte hält, dass sich dabei um eine Sabotage gehandelt hat, wo die Amerikaner dafür gesorgt haben, dass Steuerungsbauteile, die in Pumpstationen in so einer russischen Gaspipeline verwendet wurden, dazu geführt haben, dass an einer Stelle halt eine stehende Welle entstand in der Gaspipeline, die dann zu einer Explosion führte. Und die Geschichte ist halt nicht unumstritten. Also gibt es eine Menge Leute, die sagen, dass die Bullshit ist, also so halt nicht stattgefunden hat, oder es halt irgendwie ganz anders war und die Amis sich dann irgendwie auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben.
Naja, so richtig offiziell auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben, aber auch nicht, oder?
Naja, oder auf die Fahnen gerüchtet haben, oder so.
Das ist überhaupt der vereinheitlichende Punkt an diesen ganzen Geschichten, dass normalerweise niemand zugibt, es gewesen zu sein. Das war jetzt echt erstaunlich und hat auch viele Leute wirklich überrascht, dass die Amis aus Wahlkampfgründen gesagt haben, Stuxnet sei sie gewesen.
Aber nochmal auf die historischen Kontext zurückzukommen. Ich hab mal geguckt, was das Weiteste zurück ist, was ich finden kann, wo tatsächlich Hacker, also Hacker, die nicht für irgendeine Regierung sowieso schon arbeiten, ihre Dienste in eine gestellt haben. Und was ich ganz witzig fand, eigentlich habt ihr angefangen. Also, naja, markus Hess, die Geschichte mit Clifford Stoll, der dann seine Capabilities an den KGB verticken wollte, ist CTC Hannover.
Umfeld.
Also fällt euch ein früherer Case ein?
Na ja, wahrscheinlich gab es welche, aber keine, die irgendwie bekannt geworden sind.
Also es ist der Weiteste zurück, den ich finden konnte.
Zumindest wo Hacker im geheimnistlichen Kontext unterwegs waren und eingesetzt waren. Das ist tatsächlich der Weiteste zurückliegende Fall. Es gab noch andere Fälle, wo zum Beispiel Luftverteilungssysteme angegriffen wurden. Also die sind so Capabilities, die immer wieder gerüchtet werden. Mittlerweile reden die Amis auch relativ offen davon, dass sie in der Lage sind, über entsprechend modulierte Radaremissionen Luftverteilungssysteme zu exploiten. Es gibt auch Berichte, so Biografien von irgendwelchen Special Forces Leuten, dass die zum Beispiel im Irak abgeschmissen wurden vor der Invasion, um an Faserknotenpunkten mysteriöses Equipment zu installieren. Und über diese Fasern lief wohl unter anderem die Luftverteidigung.
Also das finde ich ja glaubwürdig. Aber als ich gehört habe, dass sie mit modulierten Radar-Wegstationen angegriffen wurden, dachte ich mir so, hüpp, Bullshit.
Na wieso? Ich meine, glaubst du, dass irgendwie der auswertungscode da drinnen irgendwie so viel besser ist als alle anderen C-Code, den du kennst?
Nein, also ich will nicht bestreiten, dass es denkbar ist, aber ich halte es für ziemlich ungläubig.
Es sieht wahrscheinlich genauso schön aus wie ein VW C-Codec.
Ich halte es. Ist halt irgendwelche DSP-Scheiße, na klar.
Na und? Ich meine, guck mal, mit meinen Basements kannst du auch immer so angreifen.
Ja, weil da viel Signaling drin ist. Aber da kriegst du doch kein Signaling rein.
Da hast du Front-Wanderkennungssysteme drin.
Das ist in der Tat was anderes.
Die tatsächlich relativ große digitale Datenpakete und Krypto und Phonebar haben. Und die werden halt durchaus mit in den Radarstrom, in die Returns mit rein modelliert.
Da gab es ja diese tolle Geschichte, die sich leider als falsch herausgestellt hat in einem Buch von Ross Anderson mit der MIG in the Middle Attack.
Wie, die war falsch?
Die war leider falsch.
Okay, erzähl sie doch mal die Geschichte, weil sie so flimper.
Die Geschichte war, Südafrika hat sich irgendwelche MIGs gekauft und wollte ein Nachbarland bombardieren. Ich weiß nicht mehr, welches. Und schickt halt die MIGs los und die haben Hilfe gehabt. Nein, also nicht falsch, die haben keine MIGs gehabt, sondern die haben eben aus Embargogründen ihre eigenen ranzigen Flugzeuge gehabt, die eben keine westliche Technologie hatten und deswegen haben sie auch ihr eigenes Freund-Feind-Erkennungssystem bauen müssen. Und die Verteidigung des anderen Landes mithilfe der russen soll angeblich gewesen sein, dass sie mit der MIG zwischen die Luftabwehrstellung der Südafrikaner und deren eigenen Flugzeuge, die gerade beim Bomben waren, geflogen sind und dann man in den Mittel gemacht haben auf die Freund-Feind-Erkennung, was ein typischer Angriff auf schlecht gemachte Kryptosysteme ist.
Also sprich, weitergeleitet der...
Die haben einfach der Bodenstation gegenüber behauptet, sie seien das Flugzeug, indem sie die Pakete von dem weitergeleitet haben und haben dem Flugzeug gegenüber so getan, dann seien sie die Bodenstation. Und dann hat eben die Bodenstation beiden geglaubt, dass sie in Südafrika in das Flugzeug sind und nicht angeschossen. Und dann ist diese eine MIG, also völlig unangetastet, einmal nach Südafrika geflogen. So geht die Geschichte und hat...
War es nicht genau andersrum? War es nicht so, dass sie...
Nein, die MIG kam eben nicht aus Südafrika, sondern aus dem Angriff in den Land. Die hat halt demonstriert mit diesem Angriff, dass sie einmal komplett irgendwie über diese Station rübergeflogen ist, einmal Winke-Winke gemacht, irgendwie eine strategische Bombe abgeworfen und dann wird der Krieg zu Ende, weil die Südafrikaner gesehen haben, dass sie ein Problem haben.
War es nicht genau andersrum? War es nicht so, dass die Südafrikaner die russen exploitet haben? Aber jedenfalls war die Geschichte falsch.
Die Geschichte war leider falsch.
Schade, okay.
Na ja, MIG ist ja nun kein südafrikanisches Flugzeug. Na eben. Insofern muss... Und wenn die MIG in der Mitte ist...
Gut, okay, müssen wir nochmal nachlesen.
Aber ist egal, hat ja zurückgezogen die Geschichte.
Schade, die war zu schön.
Aber gut, sowas kann man noch... Das ist noch glaubwürdig, aber das ist jemand...
Das ist durchaus passiert bei solchen Sachen wie Luftverteidigung. Und das ist mir... Ja, viele solche Sachen werden ja, und das muss man vielleicht kurz erklären, Chatham house Rules erzählt, wo man dann nicht sagen kann, wer es erzählt hat, aber man darf erzählen, was erzählt wurde.
Da werden wir uns auch dran halten, selbstverständlich.
Wir werden nicht sagen, wer es war. Chatham house Rules ist eine Art, Konferenzen durchzuführen, die dazu dienen soll, dass die Leute frei untereinander reden können. Und der Deal ist halt, man kann die Informationen, die da erzählt werden, verwenden und erzählen. Aber man darf nicht mehr sagen, auf welcher Konferenz es stattgefunden hat, aber nicht von wem es gesagt wurde.
Ja.
Und da sind ein paar Storys, so in den letzten Jahren aufgetaucht, wo es tatsächlich so um Kalibrierung geht. Also oft ist es ja so, dass man ein Sack voll Waffensysteme kauft, ein paar Wunden hat von irgendwas. Und dann hat man zwei, die werden ganz genau eingemessen, blablabla, und dann nimmt man halt die Kalibrierungsdaten und kopiert die auf alle anderen. Und es ist wohl jetzt schon ein paar Mal vorgekommen, tatsächlich in europäischen Ländern, dass man dann mal so nach ein paar Jahren mal nachgemessen hat, was so die in so viel deployed Geschichten, meistens Luftverteidigung, was sie denn so für Kalibrierungswerte haben und das alles irgendwie die Chancen halt auf den Mond. Also das war halt totaler Mist und dann stellte sich raus, dass irgendjemand mal ganz entspannt, irgendwie mit einem akkuschrauber, irgendwie ein paar Schrauben in die Festplatte, von dem die Kalibrierung dann kopiert wurde, mal so reingebohrt hat und das merkte dann keiner und die kopierten dann halt irgendwie Mumpitz-uninitialisierte Daten auf alle anderen Systeme. Und da gab es nicht nur eine Story von, es ist also offensichtlich so ein beliebtes geheimdienstmuster, wo man dann, da braucht man jetzt keine Schadsoftware für, aber man exploitet halt einfach den Prozess, wie die Kalibrierungsdaten dann in der Welt verteilt werden.
Kann man das erzählen mit den AKWs? Na, wir hatten mal so ein Gespräch, da wollen wir auch mal nicht sagen mit wem, aber da war eins der Szenarien genau das, dass die Atomkraftwerke ja Sensoren haben. Und wenn man so ein AKW angreifen wollte, eine der Stellen, die da möglich sind, ist eben, dass man den Typ angreift, der die Kalibrierung macht und das der eben die beim Eichen immer das ein bisschen nach oben verschiebt oder was weiß ich, nach unten nehmen und dass das AKW dann nicht merkt, wenn es in gefährliche Bereiche kommt. Weil es gibt Schranken dafür, wie weit man leichen darf, in Abweichung von dem, was vorher war. Also die haben schon generell an den Angriff gedacht, aber wenn es eine längerfristige Sache ist, das ist ein Problem, insbesondere wenn man outsourcet.
Interessant ist, dass viele von diesen Sachen unter dem großen Thema Electronic Warfare schon seit Ewigkeiten sind. Die spielen schon seit vielen Jahrzehnten da so Katz und maus mit ihren Radars und ihren Frontfeinderkennungssystemen und ihren Funksystemen. Im mediterrischen Bereich ist das durchaus eine übliche Sache. In der Regel werden mediterrische Systeme zumindest ein Stück weit dagegen gehärtet. Also wenn man davon ausgehen muss, dass der Gegner halt über entsprechende Fähigkeiten verfügt, dann versucht man halt irgendwie, sich nicht total prasslich anzustellen und also irgendwie dafür zu sorgen, dass bestimmte Exploits nicht möglich sind oder dass man daran gedacht hat und so weiter. Aber trotzdem ist es so, dass offensichtlich immer noch eine große Menge von solchen Sachen funktionieren. Also die russen rätseln wohl bis heute, wie die Israelis es geschafft haben, das syrische Luftverteilungssystem auszuhebeln, um diesen Reaktor da zu bombardieren. Die Syrer haben wohl nichts gesehen, was so nachzulesen ist.
Die haben wohl das rechts unten Modell gekauft, sollen wir dazu sagen. Die haben die russische Luftverteilung im Modell rechts unten gekauft. Und die Israelis sind reingeflogen, haben gebombt, sind wieder weggeflogen und die Syrer haben nicht mal gemerkt, dass sie bombardiert werden.
Genau.
Was ja schon eher peinlich ist.
So und da gibt es eben auch das Gerücht, dass die Israelis halt offenbar diese russische Luftverteilungssysteme halt einfach erxploitet haben, weil die Israelis haben halt keine nennenswerten Stealth-Capabilities. Das, was sie da haben sind, F-14 und F-16, die haben halt jede Menge Electronic Warfare-Equipment mit in Israel anbaut, aber halt keine richtige Stealth-Variante. Das heißt, die müssen halt offensichtlich Wege gefunden haben, das halt so zu exploiten, dass sie da durchgekommen sind. Interessant daran ist aber eben diese, wie sehr die Fantasie angeregt wird durch dieses ganze Cyberwar-Dings da so, sie werden uns die Stromnetze runterfahren und so ist ja so ein... Und deswegen gibt es halt immer wieder Geschichten, was ist sich als in Brasilien, weil so ein großer stromausfall war zum Beispiel, da gab es halt irgendwie auch so die Geschichte, ja, war auch wie Cyber-Angriff oder so und dann gab es irgendwie einen stromausfall in den USA, die mit, was war es, Slammer, glaube ich, koinzidierte. Also halt zu dem Zeitpunkt, als Slammer unterwegs war, wo halt unklar ist, ob es jetzt halt irgendwie sozusagen ein versehenliches Runterfahren war, weil irgendwie dieser Slammerwurm halt irgendwie da sich wieder durchgebissen hatte bis in irgendwelche Steuerzentralen oder ob es irgendwie einfach nur eine Korrelation war, die keine kausation war in dem zeitlichen zusammenhang.
Naja, man darf ja dann nicht übersehen, dass irgendwie gerade bei Slammer und Naci, also bei so Würmern, die über UDP und so viel die CPU herinfiziert haben, einfach auch reihenweise CISCO-Equipment und Juniper-Equipment gegen die Wand geknallt ist, weil sie versuchten, die Pakete von ANAP zu schrieben. Also als der Naci-Wurm losgegangen ist, war ich gerade auf irgendeiner Blackhead und dann unterhielt mich gerade mit einem CISCO-Piecer-Typen, dann klingelte sein Telefon und er rannte zum Taxi und schrie ja ein Problem. Ja, wenn dir dann die ganze Netzwerkeinfrastruktur einfach nur baden geht, dann...
Gut, dann fällt auch schon mal der Strom aus, das kann man nachvollziehen.
Also ich hab ja so ein paar Geschichten gehört von Kraftwerken, die die halt... Also das war immer die Hauptverteidigung in der Argumentation, wir kriegen keine Würmer, weil wir keinen Internetzugang haben. Und das heißt aber auch, dass die Leute dann ihre Systeme nicht updaten, weil Update geht über Internet und Internet haben wir nicht und dann haben die da halt irgendwelche Windows 98, sag ich mal.
Die Argumentation mit, wir kriegen keine Würmer, weil ergab, habe ich irgendwie in der satellite-industrie neulich gehört, wo sie meinten, irgendwie unser Control Center kann man nicht angreifen, weil die hängen nicht am Internet und dann meinte jemand, meinte irgendwie...
Hängen nicht am Internet?
Hängen nicht am Internet und dann meinte...
Das kann man aber kaufen, Internet über Satellit, was wir...
Meinte einer, ja, das ist aber komisch, weil irgendwie eure Leute gehen noch abends nach hause und wie macht ihr denn dann Operations? Na, wir VPN-Reihen. Oh, okay, alles klar, kein Internet.
Das ist nicht neu, das ist ein ganz anderes Internet.
Nicht das große böse Internet, nein, nein.
Jedenfalls passiert es halt immer wieder, dass irgendwelche Kraftwerke auch heute noch mit irgendwelchen antiken Würmern infiziert werden, weil irgendein Servicetechniker da reinläuft mit seinem Laptop und das... Der macht halt sonst nirgendwo Schaden, weil diese Würmer alle natürlich irgendwelche Probleme ausnutzen, die seit Jahren gefixt sind, aber wenn der in so ein museumskraftwerk reingeht, was noch nie geupdatet wurde, das gibt es immer noch, dass irgendwelche wirklich, also so Slammer, Code-Red-Dinger in irgendwelchen Infrastrukturen gefunden werden, nach zehn Jahren.
Ja, du darfst auch nicht vergessen, dass es da einen Haufen Equipment gibt, wo zum Beispiel so Windows XP drin SP0 verbaut ist, was zertifiziert ist und dass die Zertifizierung verliert, sobald du da einen Patch einspielst oder eine AV drauf machst.
Das ist alles so unglaublich. Die interessante Frage ist ja, wie viel ist denn jetzt eigentlich an dieser Panik dran? Also wie verwundbar ist denn eigentlich tatsächlich die kritische Infrastruktur, so Stromversorgung, Wasserversorgung, Telekommunikation?
Ist das wirklich die Frage? Ich finde die Frage andersrum viel interessanter, wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass die tatsächlich targeted angegriffen wird? Und da ist wieder genau die nächste Frage.
Die telco-industrie fährt sich ja schon ohne externe Hilfe runter.
Die Frage ist ja eben tatsächlich, wenn man jetzt mal versucht, diesen Hype so ein bisschen zu klassifizieren, dann gibt es ja da diese Digital-Per-Haber-Fraktion und die gehen alle davon aus, dass irgendwer Malware in ihre Stromnetze droppt oder sowas.
Aber guck mal, kommen wir zurück auf diese ganzen Definitionen, kriegerischer Akt und Genfer Konvention und sowas. Niemand, also niemand in der sagen wir mal ersten Welt, der irgendwo höher im Militär ist oder höher in der Politik ist, wird sich das irgendwie auf einen Zettel schreiben, dass er jetzt mal ein Land runtergefahren hat und potentiell dann irgendwie die nächste Amtszeit nicht mehr machen kann, sondern erst mal in den Haken irgendwie ein paar Leute ein paar Antworten geben muss. Also ich sehe halt einfach, das Karriere-Risiko für die Leute, die das entscheiden können, ist so hoch, dass den großflächigen Angriff, den sehe ich eigentlich nicht. Ich sehe halt vielmehr irgendwie diese targeted Geheimdienstaktionen.
Na die Infrastruktur ist doch aber so ranzig bei uns, dass wenn du da an einem kleinen Seiten-Eingang wackelst, das ganze Gebäude dir entgegenkommt.
Ja, ist ja deine Verantwortung als Angreifer.
Es ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so einfach, den Angriff vorsichtig zu wackeln.
Also was ich das größere Problem finde, ist, dass du einfach die Militärziele nicht erreichst, wenn du das Stromnetz von so einem Land runterfährst. Also die Militärbasen haben halt ihre eigenen Generatoren, die dann anspringen. Das mag vielleicht nicht ewig.
Aber wenn sie denn Benzin reingemacht haben.
Es gibt ja, oder falls sie, wie zum Beispiel die Bundeswehr, ob sie in der Lage ist, durch ihr tolles SAP, irgendwie Benzin für diese Generatoren zu ordern. Ist ja auch noch eine interessante Frage.
Ich glaube, da gibt es eine Geschichte, die wir hören wollen.
Naja, also ich hatte da mal so eine diskussion mit so einem Bundeswehr-General, der unter anderem sich darüber ausliest, wie halt irgendwie die Bundeswehr halt irgendwie ihre sogenannte White-IT, also alles, was jetzt nicht irgendwie waffenbezogen ist, an so ein Konsortium aus irgendwie IBM, Siemens und...
T-Systems. Sag nicht T-Systems.
Doch, ich glaube ja. Das Projekt heißt Herkules.
Oh ja, richtig.
Und die, also sie haben es halt outgesourcelt, das ist halt so ein Monster-SAP-System und irgendwie noch tausend andere Projekte. Und der meint halt so, weißt du, naja, also solange ich nicht mal zufällig Klopapier darüber bestellen kann, würde ich jetzt Cyberwarnix hören.
Da weiß man doch, was man angreifen muss.
Es ist wohl tatsächlich die größte Einzelinstallation SAP auf der Welt.
Was could possibly go wrong? Na gut, also wir konkludieren, die Verwundbarkeit ist halt schon durchaus gegeben, weil die Infrastruktur halt irgendwie größtenteils ranzig ist und irgendwie durchaus auch angreifbar ist. Die spannende Frage ist aber eben, wer hätte dann halt eigentlich ein Interesse daran, anzugreifen, aus welchen Gründen und was mich immer wieder besonders aufregt, sind halt diese diese Cyber-Terror-Gefasler. Also ich meine, es ist ja einfach lustigerweise mittlerweile die Luft aus denen rauszulassen, weil man muss ja einfach nur mal fragen, wo ist denn eigentlich der Bioterror geblieben? Weil genau dieselben Leute waren es nämlich, die irgendwie so 2003, 2004, 2005 irgendwie mit großen Bioterror-Schildern durch die Gegend gelaufen sind, irgendwie alle Leute Gasmasken verkauft haben und irgendwie Antragsimpfstoffe und whatnot alles. Und ich meine, klar, es ist halt ganz gut, dass die Feuerwehr jetzt irgendwie endlich mal ordentliche Artenschutzgeräte bekommen hat. Also es hat durchaus auch positive Effekte gehabt, als hätte man auch viel billiger haben können. Der Grund, warum es kein Bioterror gibt, ist schlicht und ergreifend, dass irgendwie biologische Waffen als Terrorwaffe für eine terroristische Organisation weitgehend ungeeignet sind. Weil bis irgendwie klar wird, dass es sich dabei eben tatsächlich im Terrorangriff handelt, haben sie schon lange die Kontrolle über die Nachricht verloren. Und der genaue Selbe gilt halt eben für digitale Angriffe. Weil selbst wenn man dann mal das Stromnetz runterfährt, irgendwie als Terrorangriff, meine, weil jeder halbwegs denkt, einen Start machen würde, zu sagen, naja Gott war ein Computerfehler, tut uns leid, irgendwie morgen geht es wieder.
Vor allem geht ja eine Fernseher nicht, über die die Botschaft reingekommen werde, wer jetzt Schuld hat.
Zum Beispiel.
Also ich finde ja, bei diesen Biowaffen, die sind wohl auch im normalen Krieg nicht wirklich verwendbar. Also weil die einfach diverse Probleme haben. Aber gut, also ich meine, wir können festhalten, bei Wasser würde ich jetzt noch nicht sagen. Gut doch, doch eigentlich schon. Also bei Strom ist auf jeden Fall so, dass das Netz regelmäßig von alleine zusammenbricht. Gerade in Amerika, die Wasserwerke sind eigentlich auch alle runtergewirtschaftet durch die Privatisierung. Da glaubt eigentlich niemand, dass ein Angriff ist, wenn da mal wieder irgendwas nicht geht. Insofern ist das auch nicht geeignet für irgendwie öffentlicher Nahverkehr. Für Terrorverbreiten, das kennen wir schon.
Ich meine, bei öffentlichem Nahverkehr gab es ja nun tatsächlich Infrastrukturangriffe, zumindest in Berlin. Also heute irgendwie Angriffe auf die Signalisierungslettern stattgefunden haben.
Na jetzt gerade wieder bei Hannover nach Hamburg irgendwie.
Das war aber Kupferdiebstahl.
Na ja, wieso? Das ist doch auch ein Angriff auf die Infrastruktur, natürlich.
Klar, aber...
Na was denn? Das ist jetzt kein digitaler Angriff, aber wenn da jemand die Kabel rausträgt, das ist auch verkackt.
Na was denn?
Ja, nur so richtig so das Gefühl von Terror stellt sich da nicht ein, ne?
Nein, aber das ist ja gerade der Punkt, den du hören willst. Wir haben diese Angriffe schon und sie bewirken nichts.
Es ist echt schade, dass wir keine Bilder einblenden können, weil so ein Osteuropäer mit so einem Kabelbaum über den Arm unter drunter stehen so Cyber-Terroristen, wenn ich jetzt hier passen würde.
Genau, vielleicht kann das ja einer von den Hörern für uns zurechtbauen. Das kriegt ihr bestimmt hin. Na gut, dann lass uns mal ein bisschen drüber reden, wie sehen dann eigentlich die Waffen in so einem Digitalkonflikt aus? Also diese sagenumwobenen Exploits und Zero Days und diese Dinge. Vielleicht sollten wir das mal ein bisschen erklären für die Hörer, die irgendwie da in dem Gewerbe nicht so bewandert sind.
Na, wir haben hier extra einen Gast eingeladen, der das erklären kann.
Naja, also Prinzipie, was brauchst du? Also erstmal alle Sachen, die wir bis jetzt gesehen haben, haben zwar Schadsoftware-Eigenschaften, also können sie sich so ein bisschen verbreiten und so ein Kram, sind aber erst mal inneren anders. Hauptsächlich hat man irgendwie so drei, vier, fünf Komponenten. Also erstmal braucht man einen sogenannten initialen Angriffsvektor, also halt irgendeine Schwachstelle, wo man sich einen Exploit für gebaut hat, der dann möglichst auch in the wild funktioniert. Das ist nämlich auch so eine kleine Unterscheidung. Ja, also nicht jeder, der einen Exploit bauen kann, kann dann auch gleich irgendwie eine Cyberwaffe draus schrauben, weil wenn das bei dir funktioniert, dann heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das überall im Internet funktioniert, sondern da kann man dann nochmal ein paar, also man sagt so 450 Mannstunden Arbeit draufstecken, dass der Kram dann auch wirklich funktioniert, weil in dem Moment, wo du jemanden angriffst und dem crasht einfach bloß irgendwie sein Windows, hast du eigentlich schon die große Glocke dran gehängt. Hey, ich mach hier grad was. Also das Schöne an diesen Angriffen ist tatsächlich, wenn alle unsere Software so sauber gebaut wäre wie Stuxnet, dann hätten wir überhaupt keine Probleme mehr. Also qualitativ sind die schon sehr hochwertig. So, dann hab ich meine Angriffe, dann bin ich erst mal da in diesem Rechner drin, dann brauch ich ein Persistence Toolkit, also irgendwie ein Rootkit oder irgendwas anderes, dass ich mich in der Büchse verstecken kann und mich da irgendwie ausbreiten kann und so was. Dann brauche ich irgendeine Form von Command & Control, also sprich nach hause telefonieren und sagen, je, ich bin drin, was soll ich weiter machen? Module nachladen, ein bisschen Operation, also keine Ahnung, irgendwie Krypto-Keys austauschen und so weiter und so fort. Und das kann dann eigentlich auch beliebig hardcore werden. Also es gibt diesen wunderschönen Fall von einem Außenministerium, eines hier nicht genannten europäischen Landes, dass die haben tatsächlich erst nach vier Jahren gemerkt, dass sie komplett geohnt waren. Also wirklich jeder einzelne Rechner in diesem Ministerium und zwar weltweit. Und was man dann gefunden hat ist, und das war technisch einfach nur beautiful, die hatten also alle Rechner, die irgendwie Internetzugang hatten, so Sekretärin Büchse und so was, die hatten so eine Art Command-and-Control-Proxy. Der hat geguckt, wann der Rechner irgendwie Netzwerk-Traffic gemacht hat und nur dann hat er mitgequatscht, sonst hat er die Klappe gehalten. Dann haben die nach innen tatsächlich irgendwie ein Metanetz über Windows-RPC zu den Domain-Controllern aufgebaut. Alles schön peer-to-peer. Und dann konnte man von außen so Kommandos reinschicken, geh mal auf die Suche nach Dokumenten mit folgender Regex oder mit folgendem Text drin und dann verbreitete sich das so schön langsam in dem Netz und immer wenn Plattenaktivität auf einem Rechner war, dann ist halt das Rootkit dahergegangen und hat mal ein bisschen mitgesucht und wenn die Platten dann aufgehört haben, dann hörte das auch auf. Und das ist echt erst nach vier Jahren aufgefallen, weil sie irgendwo im Keller ganz hinten in der Ecke, also die hatten halt ein ganz, ganz krasses Windows-Kernel-Rootkit mit einem In-Kernel-Disassembler, so dass wenn die Kisten gepatcht wurden, das Rootkit automatisch irgendwie die neuen Offsets und die neuen Datenstrukturen gefunden hat und sich angepasst hat. Also richtig abgefahrenes Zeug und irgendwo ganz hinten in der Ecke hatten, die einen super räudigen 64-Bit-HP-Server. Und nach vier Jahren irgendwie bei einem Update machte der halt mal blaues Bildschirm. Und das große Glück von diesem Ministerium war, dass sie offensichtlich einen hinreichend inquisitiven Admin hatten, der meinte so, ne, das ist irgendwie meine Büchse, die macht sowas nicht. Und dann mal guckte und dann so, was ist denn das für ein Treiber? Und dann war natürlich erstmal irgendwie Haare raufen und so. Aber bis in diese Qualitätsstufe geht das dann. Aber sowas ist, das ist eine wichtige Eigenschaft, die zu einem gewissen Sinne sogar bei Stux auch der Fall war, auch die Sachen, die keinen Internetzugang hatten, die sind alle manually operated. Also im Unterschied zu einer Banking malware oder sowas, ist es tatsächlich so, dass da 24-7 Leute irgendwo auf der Welt sitzen und überwachen, was für einen Datenstrom gerade haben, Keys austauschen. Der Trick ist eigentlich bei diesen richtig guten Operations, dass sie das Netz von den Leuten, die sie angreifen, besser kennen als die. Also es ist wie in den 90ern, wenn du in den Rechner einbrichst, erstmal irgendwie die Sicherheitslücken patchen, damit nicht irgendwie gleich der nächste neben dir die zweite Schäl aufmacht und Platz nimmt.
Genau.
Und du dann irgendwie so Rootwars hast. Das nervt ja auch. Also der Trick bei denen ist tatsächlich, sind technisch dieselben Verfahren, aber sie sind qualitativ deutlich hochwertiger und sie sind Active Operated.
Na ja gut, ich meine Flame zum Beispiel sieht aber eigentlich eher so aus, als wenn es darauf ausgelegt wäre, eine relativ große Menge Rechner semi-automatisch zu beobachten, nachdem sie einmal infiziert worden.
Na ja klar, aber das muss ja, also gerade Flame ist ein wunderschöner Fall für Operation, wo du deine Lua-Module da reinballerst und mal guckst, was, klar du infizierst erst mal, schaust, was kommt da so raus und dann hast du ja irgendwelche Maschinen, die sozusagen dahinter hängen. Also Menschen denken ja auch immer mit diesem Perimetersicherheitsdenken und dann schmeißt du da halt mal kurz irgendwie ein Stück Skript rein, was deine Operationsleute schrauben können, wo du nicht erst irgendwie zu deinen Developern gehen musst und ein neues Modul basteln, sondern ja die Skripten dann halt irgendwie, hallo, beschaff mir mal Dokument. Also das ist ja eigentlich der Showcase für operational.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel, dass das Dinge erst mal die Metadaten von diversen Dokumenten indext und in einer Datenbank ablegt, sieht ja für mich zumindest erst mal so aus, als wenn man auf eine relativ große Menge Computer-Quarries absetzen will, in relativ automatisierter Art und Weise, oder?
Na klar. Wie gesagt, das ist ja bei diesem Außenministerium auch genauso gelaufen. Also die haben auch erst mal Metadaten, teilweise einfach irgendwie die Search-Index-Datenbank von dem Windows, was es sowieso anliegt, irgendwie so krabbel, rausschick. Und dann hat man halt erst mal so einen Überblick, was gibt es denn da zu holen? Und dann wird halt speziell angefragt. Die Operations sind ja auch nicht tatsächlich die Leute, die die Informationen haben wollen. Das sind ja eher wirklich die Techies. Und dann gibt es ja hinten dran doller hauswert-abteilung, wo dann jemand sagt, so hier davon aber mal bitte noch ein bisschen mehr und von der Frau bitte auch noch ein paar Nacktbilder.
Also mir wurde mal erzählt, von was so die Chinesen treiben in so europäischen Firmen, wo dann mal Leute ein bisschen experimentiert haben, das heißt also mal Dokumente abgelegt haben, die auf fiktive Projekte verweisen, um zu gucken, wie lange es dauert, bis ihr halt Queries dann sehen nach diesen Dokumenten. Und die Chinesen haben wohl offensichtlich so ein Turnaround-Cycle zwischen sechs und acht Tagen. Das heißt also, wenn halt die sozusagen Kram exfiltriert ist, wo halt irgendwie interessante Keywords drin sind, dann ist der nach sechs bis acht Tagen ausgeweitet und dann kommen die Keywords aus diesen Dokumenten halt wieder rein, um den nächsten Cycle zu fahren.
Schöner Clifford-Stoil-Style.
Das ist halt only-but-goldi, ne?
Ich muss ja sagen, was mich wirklich beeindruckt hat, ist, dass es überhaupt nicht unsere Vorstellung von vor 20 Jahren entsprochen hat. Weil wir haben mal gedacht, irgendwie Microsoft und die Dienste sind eh im Boot und wenn die Dienste irgendwann brauchen, dann werden sie sich da dann da sich ein Hintertür einbauen. Das war irgendwie immer die Bedrohung, von der wir ausgegangen sind und das ist überhaupt nicht passiert.
Es sind genug Bugs da.
Ja, aber ich meine, es kostet ja mehr, so ein Bug auszunutzen, als eine Hintertür zu nehmen. Nein, langfristig nicht. Das ist eben die Frage.
Also eine Hintertür hat halt irgendwie, wie wir jetzt gerade gesehen haben, zum Beispiel diesen FPGAs. So, kurze Erklärung, da haben ein paar Leute, die lustigerweise glaube ich von der britischen, dem britischen DARPA-IQ finanziert wurden, in amerikanischen FPGAs, die besonders gerne im Rüstungsbereich verwendet werden, eine offensichtliche Hintertür gefunden. Also wenn man da halt irgendwie einen längeren Key reinschickt in diesen FPGA, dann sagt er guten Tag und gibt einem alles, was er so weiß, also inklusive der Keys, mit denen eigentlich die Konfiguration dieses Chips verschlüsselt ist. Und...
Weiß ich, wir müssen noch ein paar Sachen dazusagen, hier, wenn nicht, sonst kriegen wir wieder böse Mails, und ich muss die beantworten. Also DARPA, DARPA ist eine Regierungsorganisation der Vereinigten Staaten. Da geht es darum, defensnahe Projekte, also verteidigungsnahe Projekte zu machen, die finanzieren...
Zum Beispiel das Internet.
Zum Beispiel das Internet ist ursprünglich ein DARPA-Projekt, aber die machen auch sowas wie, die haben einen Venture-Capitalarm, wo sie irgendwelche Start-ups fördern, die interessant klingen, irgendwie Drohnenforschung, sowas. Der Forschungsarm des Pentagon.
Genau, die Bretten haben sowas Ähnliches. Sie sind nicht ganz so groß und eher ein bisschen gezielter.
Heute kam die Meldung, dass Putin sowas auch aufbauen will.
Ja klar, mal macht der auch Sinn. Gut, jedenfalls FPGAs sind Chips, die man frei umprogrammieren kann, also bei denen, der die Logik auf dem Chip nicht festgelegt ist, dann programmiert wird. Und die sind besonders beliebt z.B. auch in Waffen, weil man damit relativ stressfrei, relativ schnelle Operationen, die spezifisch auf einen bestimmten Anwendungsfall zugeschnitten sind, programmieren kann. Und z.B. typisch für die bildauswertungen und Sensordatenintegrationen und so eine Sache, dafür nimmt man halt gar einen FPG-AS.
Und ist billiger als einen ASIC, weil man keine Millionen Spitzahlen hat.
Billiger als einen richtigen Chip fertigen zu lassen und vor allen Dingen flexibler, weil man einen Back drin hat, macht man halt neue Programmierungen rein und fertig.
Und es braucht weniger Strom, als eine richtige CPU einzubauen.
Na nicht zwingend, aber...
Naja, also für die normalen Anwendungen schon. Du hast ja normalerweise DSP-Krams da drauf.
Na jedenfalls, diese FPG-AS zeichnen sich dadurch aus, dass man da, also zumindest auf diesem spezifischen Ding, einen Schutz davor hat, dass der ausgelesen werden kann. Also, dass man rauskriegt, was auf diesem Chip eigentlich passiert.
Das Szenario ist, dass eine amerikanische Drohne im Iran abstürzt. Und dass der Iran wissen will, wie dann da die Software aussieht. Jetzt mal völlig aus der Luft gegriffen.
Völlig hypothetisch, genau.
Und da gibt es halt die Bug-Interfaces an diesen Chips, die man benutzen kann, um zuzugucken, was jetzt eigentlich über den bus geht. Und die sind eben geschützt bei Militärchips, damit man da nicht auslesen kann. Was auch in der zivilen industrie inzwischen eine Rolle spielt bei irgendwelchen DHM-Systemen. Also Kopierschutz für irgendwelche.
Naja, jedenfalls stellte sich halt raus, dass irgendwie, da haben sie, wie gesagt, diese Briten haben eine neue Methode entwickelt, um Schlüssel aus Chips rauszukitzeln. Also eine Erweiterung der sogenannten Differential Power Analysis. Kann man jemand nachlesen, wenn es interessiert. Die dazu geführt hat, dass sie festgestellt haben, okay, wenn man so einen langen Kider in diesen Chip reinsteckt, dann macht er, ihr sagt er guten Tag und gibt einem die ganze Konfiguration. Und ist halt ein bisschen doof.
Stellt sich aber raus, es war gar keine Backdoor. Also der Herrscher...
Na doch, aber von jemand anderem als gedacht.
Naja, das ging ja so ein bisschen hin und her. Also die Cambridge Wars, glaube ich, die mit dem Ding da raus kamen.
Die haben gesagt, das ist ja nicht die chinesische Backdoor.
Genau, die haben erstmal irgendwie einen Riesenfass aufgemacht und so die PR-Tüte geblasen. Und das ging ja dann so ein bisschen hin und her. Da hat der Hersteller was gesagt, dann haben die wieder was gesagt, dann haben sie ein bisschen rumgeeiert und so weiter und so fort. Es stellt sich tatsächlich raus. Also mein letzter Stand ist, dass es sich tatsächlich um einen ganz normalen Hersteller-Key handelt. Es gibt sozusagen, naja Moment, es geht ja um das JTAG-Interface. Und der Hersteller sagt seinen Kunden, die diese Chips kaufen, hier gibt es zwei Keys. Ihr könnt einen eigenen dazusetzen. Dann muss man tatsächlich beide haben. Also sprich, man muss den Drohnenhersteller-Key und den Wendor-Key von dem FPGA-Hersteller haben, um das auszulesen. Das ist aber wohl, ich sag mal, nicht so richtig laut dokumentiert. Das heißt, irgendwie...
So ein Feature in der Passivvermarktung, ja?
Was ist das denn? Das Ding ist, die Cambridge-Leute haben sich einfach so ein Teil bestellt, haben halt auch nicht anständig gelesen und haben dann erst mal daran ihre neue Technik ausprobiert und dann, joho, wir haben was gefunden und es waren die Chinesen.
Ja, lustigerweise mit den Chinesen haben ja nicht die Cambridge-Leute gesagt, sondern die Reporter, die es als erstes geschrieben haben, das war das lustige. Cyber-Foo-Backdoors müssten erst mal nicht gelesen sein.
Es gibt ja auch diese uralte Story, die ständig gerade auf solchen Konferenzen von Leuten, die das nur aus der Presse bewerten können, wieder repeated wird mit dem gefälschten Cisco-Bauteilen, die in Staaten gefunden wurden vom FBI. Da gab es da eine riesen Raids, weil sie irgendwie Cisco-Line-Cards gefunden haben, die nicht so richtig schön verarbeitet waren. Der Punkt ist, wir haben bis heute noch nicht einen einzigen Fall, wo man zeigen kann, dass die Chinesen irgendwo eine Backdoor eingebaut haben. Wir haben einen Haufen Backdoors gefunden, aber die waren alle von den Amis.
Überraschung!
Na gut, es gibt einen Fall, wo die Frage ist, ob es eine Backdoor ist. Das ist halt ZTE, die haben ein Telefon verbaut, wo Software drauf war, die man eigentlich...
Dieses Make-Me-Root-Teil?
Genau.
Und das ist ja eigentlich, wie man eine Backdoor baut. Also eigentlich baust du ja eine Backdoor so, dass du im allerbesten Fall sagen kannst, es war eine Verwundbarkeit. Also es war ein sicher... Hups, bedauerlicher Fehler. Genau, bedauerlicher Fehler. Also bei einigen chinesischen Produkten, wenn man sich da den Code anguckt, kann man schon von Vorsatz reden, aber das Blöde ist, wenn du dir den Siemens-Code anguckst, kannst du dasselbe behaupten.
Also der Fachbegriff, der ist so eine Debug-Door. Und das ist eigentlich auch der weitaus clevere Weg, den wahrscheinlich sowieso alle verwenden wollen. Offensichtliche Backdoors einzubauen, ist halt strategisch äußerst unklug.
Heutzutage macht keiner mehr Vergleiche. Passwort mit Secret Source und dann Open Door oder so.
Genau, das heißt also die Idee, dass Leute Backdoors einbauen, die halt offensichtlich halt solche zu erkennen sind beim Reverse-Engineering, die ist halt offensichtlich vorbei. Einfach deswegen, weil einfach zu viele Leute gibt, die mittlerweile Reverse-Engineering beherrschen und solche Sachen, also die offensichtliche Backdoors sind auch finden können.
Es gibt da ja einen schönen Contest zu, den Underhanded-C-Contest, den kann man mal pluggen bei der Gelinge. Das ist der zivile Arm der backdoor-industrie. Da geht es nämlich darum, dass der Wettbewerb geht, sodass die ein Problem stellen und man soll das so implementieren, dass jemand, der den Code anguckt und selbst wenn er weiß, dass eine Backdoor drin ist, nicht sofort sieht, wo die ist. Das heißt, das Problem ist sowas wie, zum Beispiel wir haben ein Foto aufgenommen mit dem Sensor und da soll irgendwie diese Nachricht versteckt werden. Ja und man soll halt ein Programm abgeben, was dann a. diese Nachricht einbaut und b. nachweist, dass sie drin ist. Und der Code wird dann veröffentlicht und irgendwie das Internet at large darf dann teilnehmen und sagen irgendwie, hm, das könnte eine Backdoor sein. Und also das ist auch ein interessantes Problem, weil das so ein Henne-Eiding ist. Je mehr man weiß, dass da eine Backdoor drin ist und einer erwartet, desto mehr sieht man dann auch eine, selbst wenn keine drin ist. Ja, das ist also...
So, wer mit der Brille des Aquas schaut, der sieht die Raupen selbst im Sauerkraut.
Genau, so sieht's aus.
Na gut, egal, ob's jetzt nun ein absichtlich eingebauter Bug oder ein absichtlich dringelassener Bug oder ein, ja, ja...
Woran erkennt man den Firmen, die keine Bugs einbauen? Sind das die mit Bugbunty-Programm?
Bugbunty?
Nein, die interessante Frage ist ja eben, wie funktioniert denn die Politik dabei? Also es gibt ja schon sehr lange Berichte darüber, dass es halt gerade im amerikanischen Raum, also in der Geheimdienst-Ecke so ein Vulnerability-Committee-Strukturen gibt, wo die, also gerade die NSA bei großen amerikanischen Herstellern requesten kann, bestimmte Bugs mal noch ein bisschen länger ungefixt zu lassen, weil sie die gerade strategisch brauchen.
Nein, das heißt ja mal, dass es an die Exporterlaubnis gekoppelt ist, als Druckmittel. Kann man da irgendwas zu sagen? Also ich meine, es klingt glaubwürdig, aber...
Ich finde es plausibel, aber es gibt natürlich keinen Nachweis oder auslass.
Ich würde erklären, warum man in 2009 eine CA-Infrastruktur mit einem Server von 2003 baut.
Ja, also...
Das ist doch eher Zertifizierung, oder? Ja, wir sind noch nicht so weit. Das nächste kommt noch...
Ja, das ist dann der nächste Schritt, das sozusagen Buckdoor by Process, ne? Also wenn...
Ja. Zertifizierung als strategische Sollbruchstelle.
Ja, gut, aber wie nutzt man denn... Also wenn man so einen Buck jetzt findet und den ausnutzt, da ist ja häufiger jetzt die Rede von diesen sogenannten Vulnerability Markets, also davon, dass Leute halt irgendwie so eine Exploits verkaufen.
Na, wir können ja einen Schritt vorher anfangen. Nehmen wir an, du bist jetzt ein Heimdienst und du möchtest gern so einen Buck kaufen. Also du möchtest einen Buck haben. Wo kriegst du den hier? Warum kaufen dich einfach Leute, die für sie Buck suchen? Oder machen sie das auch?
Also da ist man sicher unterschiedlicher Meinung. Ich denke, da muss man unterscheiden, die Leute, die das schon länger machen, und die Leute, die das seit gestern machen.
Es hängt vom Land ab auf Deutsch, ne?
Genau. Es gibt so Länder wie USA oder Singapur zum Beispiel, hat schon 2001 irgendwie gesagt, so wir bauen uns jetzt hier mal eine Cyber-Army hin. Die haben eine relativ greifende Begründung dafür gehabt. Die haben nämlich einfach keinen Platz für eine richtige. Also man muss sich überlegen, dass die komplette Army von Singapur tatsächlich in Thailand rumspringt. Also die haben in Thailand irgendwie so ein Stück Dschungel gemietet, für ein paar hundert Jahre. Und wenn du bei der Armee bist, dann wirst du halt darüber gefahren und dann machst du halt Dschungelkrieg. Und das ist total geil, wenn du vom Flughafen irgendwie in die Stadt reinfährst. Ich habe mich immer gewundert, dass die Straße so schnurgrade ist und in der Mitte immer so große Blumenkübel stehen. Also wirklich so fünf Mal fünf Meter Blumenkübel. Also riesen Teile. Und wenn du dann am Flughafen ankommst, dann stehen da niegelnagelneue Bulldozer. Und man erklärte mir dann, naja, das für einen Verteidigungsfall. Was die nämlich machen, ist, wenn Verteidigungsfall ist, dann kommen diese Bulldozer, fahren diese Blumenkübel alle zur Seite und dann hat man da Start- und Landebahn. Also dafür ist die Autobahn da.
Wie im Osten. Also in der DDR gab es genau das selbe Prinzip.
Und die haben halt einfach gesagt, ey, wir haben keinen Platz irgendwie für ein richtiges Militär. Aber wir haben eine Menge smarte IT-Leute. Wir bauen uns jetzt irgendwie in die Cyber-Arme hin. Also die, die so vor einer Dekade angefangen haben, die haben natürlich gute Truppen. Und da das damals noch nicht so hochgehalten war, hatten die auch genügend Zeit, irgendwie da zu trainieren. Und ich denke, die sitzen auf sizable amounts. Bugs, die haben da irgendwie ihr Arsenal und ärgern sich immer, wenn eine neue Windows-Version rauskommt.
Wie kann man das von außen beurteilen? Trifft man die auf Konferenzen oder wie läuft das?
Naja, die das schon eine Weile machen, ein bisschen Fluktuation hat man ja in solchen Einrichtungen auch. Es ist tatsächlich so, da gibt es halt einfach Leute, die da sechs, sieben Jahre bei irgendeiner Einrichtung gearbeitet haben und irgendwann mal zu einer anderen Firma gegangen sind, die sowas nicht mehr machen und dann halt bei einem Bier mal erzählen oder so. Wie gesagt, manche Länder machen sich da auch nicht so sehr ins Hemd. Also, Singapur ist da recht offen mit. Heutzutage, also die jetzt so auf den Zug aufspringen wollen, die Bundeswehr zum Beispiel. Naja, Moment, die gucken noch, wo der Bahnhof ist. Aber die, die so auf den Zug aufspringen wollen, die gehen sicherlich daher und kaufen sich erst mal so eine grundausstattung. Oder was sie denken, was eine grundausstattung ist. Das ist ja angenehmerweise, gibt es ja da nicht wirklich viele Berater. Das heißt, die müssen das nicht ja alles selber aus der Nase ziehen.
Früher war der so, da gab es noch so Responsibles Closure und Full Disclosure und so. Wenn jemand so einen Bug gefunden hat, dann hat er es als Ehre und Anerkennung betrachtet, den zu publizieren und den Herstellern ein bisschen zu trieten.
Es gab ja auch kein Geld dafür. Das darf man ja nicht vergessen. Also die Alternative gab es ja noch nicht.
Zumindest nicht in dem Maße wie heute. Also wenn war ja eher selten, dass Bugs verkauft wurden.
Das waren eher Admins, die sauer waren, weil die Hersteller sich gewirrt haben, die Bugs zu fixen. Wenn du keinen Exploit geliefert hast. Das war früher echt furchtbar. Du bist halt hingegangen, hast gesehen, wenn ich dieses Paket verschicke, gibt es einen Blue Screen. Und dann kam IBM, in deren Lahnmanager das war, und sagte, dann verschicke ich halt das Paket nicht. So, hier gibt es keinen Bug. Und dann wurde halt nicht gefixt. Und dann haben die Leute gesagt, so geht es ja nicht, und haben im Usenet gepostet.
Full disclosure halt.
Ja. Und daraufhin gab es dann so ein bisschen Druck auf die Hersteller. Und viele haben dann auch angefangen, ihre Scheiße zu fixen. Also die schönste Geschichte, die ich mir an die mich erinnere, war so ein HP. Da hat sich so ein Typ hingestellt und gesagt, HP ist Scheiße. Ich werde jetzt jede Woche den Remote Exploit veröffentlichen. Bis die mich kaufen. So bis die mich irgendwie hier, hat mich gesagt, wie viel Kohle er haben will. Das war halt Verhandlungssache.
Ja, die True64-Nummer.
Ja, und hat sich halt hingestellt und hat wirklich jede Scheißwoche einen Exploit veröffentlichen. Und hat es irgendwie ein halbes Jahr durchgehalten. Und HP ist irgendwie, ihr ist das Advisory für diese Woche. Und irgendwann war das schluss. Also das weiß jetzt keiner genau, ob der gekauft wurde.
Nee, die haben Legal War mit dem angefangen. Also die haben den Legally platt gemacht. Also richtig an die Details erinnere ich mich auch nicht mehr. Aber das war doch hier die HP 264 Bugs. Das war ja alles aufs selbe Betriebssystem. Und der hat dann irgendwie recht viel, recht viel gerechtlichen Ärger gehabt. Und also zivilrechtlich. Und die haben sich dann irgendwie geeinigt, dass sie hören auf ihn zu verklagen und er hört auf, irgendwie Exploits zu publishen oder so.
Aber da sieht man mal, dass die Hersteller im Grunde vor diesem Full-Disclosure-Zug überhaupt keinen wirtschaftlichen Grund hatten, ihre Produkte besser zu machen.
Na gut, aber am Ende war dann so, dass irgendwie Full-Disclosure endete in no more free Bugs, ne?
Nee, Full-Disclosure lief eigentlich wunderbar weiter, bis irgendwann die Hersteller anfingen zu sagen, naja Moment, aber das Argument dafür war doch immer, dass wir uns weigern, die Bugs zu fixen. Tun wir gar nicht mehr. Hier gibt uns doch die Bugs und wir fixen die dann. Und aber als Gegenleistung dürft ihr dann nicht irgendwie die Sache direkt der Öffentlichkeit geben, sondern ihr müsst uns Gelegenheit geben, das zu fixen. Das war dann Responsibles Closure.
Genau.
Und das lief auch ganz gut, bis dann die Leute angefangen haben, Monate auf den Bugs zu sitzen. Weil es gab halt irgendwie keine feste zusage von wegen, wir brauchen jetzt eine Woche und dann ist es gefixt.
Naja, also meine Erfahrung mit CISCO und die letzten neun, die ich bei CISCO abgeworfen habe, haben sie irgendwie ein und dreiviertel Jahr gebraucht und dann einen übersehen.
Super, übersehen, nachdem du ihnen das Geschicht hast, auf Feier. Das ist halt der Nachteil, wenn es keine Veröffentlichung mehr gibt, dann gibt es eben auch keinen Druck auf den Hersteller, die Scheiße zu fixen. Und die Hersteller haben überhaupt keinen Anlass, die Scheiße zu fixen, weil, welches Argument hast du dann noch, die Nachfolgeversion zu kaufen?
Naja, aber dann ging ja, also aus dieser diskussion heraus, entstand ja dann nicht nur eben aus dem Waffenprogramm heraus, sondern eben doch daraus, dass die Leute gesagt haben, naja, ich reiß mir hier den Arsch auf, um irgendwie diese Bugs zu finden und ihr behandelt mich immer noch wie ein Stück Scheiß, jetzt will ich mal Geld dafür, entstand ja dann diese No More Free Bugs Bewegung.
Ja, na, erstmal ging es halt damit los, dass die Firmen zwar die Bugs entgegen genommen haben, aber dann keinen Credit verteilt haben. Da gab es einige Firmen, die das gemacht haben und da haben die Leute dann gesagt, naja, warum soll ich dir dann den Bug überhaupt geben, wenn ich da nichts von habe?
Ich glaube, die Reihenfolge ist auch nicht so, dass die des No More Free Bugs einfach so vom Himmel gefallen ist, sondern es gab schon, naja, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es schon eine Zeit lang, also so ein paar Jahre, die Möglichkeit tatsächlich mit Bugs Geld zu verdienen. Also so die ersten ZDI, Tipping Point und so weiter, die in die ersten Firmen, die Vulnabilities gekauft haben, waren ja tatsächlich IDS-Hersteller und EPS-Hersteller.
Na ja, nach außen, man weiß gar nicht.
Die Diener-Signatur.
Wir müssen kurz die Akronym erläutern.
Okay, also so intrusion Detection, intrusion Prevention-Systeme. So was wie ein Virenscanner in der Box ist genauso hilfreich. Nämlich gar nicht. Aber kostet mehr.
Das ist im Grunde eine Kiste, die man in sein Netz stellt und der sieht halt, wenn irgendwie bösartiger Traffic vorbeikommt in der Theorie und schützt dich dann vor dem Traffic.
Ja, also eigentlich schafft er erst mal ein 500-faches Angriffsfläche von deinem PC. Man nimmt halt erst mal das IPS hoch und dann alles andere. Aber deren Idee, das funktioniert halt genauso wie bei Virenscannern. Da kennt man dann eine Signatur und dann matcht man auf die Signatur. Ist auch sehr schön, wenn man solchen Leuten dann irgendwie so Signaturen schickt. Das habe ich mal mit Cisco gemacht, wo ich so einen Bug nicht fixen wollte. Dann habe ich irgendwie die E-Mail-Adresse von einem Typen da reingepackt und dann hat sie dann... Als Carbon Copy?
Carbon Copy CDI oder was?
Nee, die E-Mail-Adresse von einem Cisco-Typen, der irgendwie von meinem Vortrag geklaut hatte. Und das hatte ich mit in ein IPSEC-Paket, also verschlüsselt, einfach so mit reinkopiert. Die haben den Hexdump natürlich nicht gecheckt, sondern direkt als Signatur abgelegt, weil es hieß, dass bei Cisco im Netz jedes Mal die IDS irgendwie Alarm schlugen, wenn der eine E-Mail kriegte. Es hat eine Weile gedauert, dass sie das gemerkt haben. Also so ungefähr funktioniert das. Und die Firmen, die so was herstellen, die haben dann halt angefangen, für die Bugs zu zahlen. Die haben gesagt, pass auf, lieber Researcher, wir nehmen dir die Arbeit mit dem Hersteller zu reden ab, stellen sicher, dass da dein Name dransteht und du gibst uns den Bug vorher, damit wir nämlich schon mal eine Signatur haben. Und wenn der Bug dann rauskommt, das sieht man heute noch bei Tippingpoint, entstehen da unsere Kundenwaren seit dann und dann, als sie den Bug gekauft haben, irgendwie dagegen schon geschützt. Ich denke, in der Reihenfolge lief das das erst mal, weil das war ja noch nicht viel Geld. Da kriegt man, keine Ahnung, ein paar hundert. So 300 oder so was. US-Dollar wohlgemerkt.
Na ja, die waren damals, waren die noch...
Ja, noch weniger, glaube ich. Und da fing das dann an, dass Leute gesehen haben, okay, man kann damit zumindest etwas Geld verdienen. Das hat aber noch nicht gereicht. Und als diese Programme sich sozusagen etabliert hatten, fiel dann anderen auf, na ja, wir können genau so ein Programm aufsetzen, aber wir müssen ja nicht daraus Signaturen bauen, sondern vielleicht können wir das ja weiterverkaufen. Und wie das jetzt irgendwie zeitlich auf den Zeitstrahl abgelaufen ist, kriege ich nicht mehr so genau zusammen. Aber dann kam erst No More Free Bugs. Das ist ja relativ recent gewesen.
Na, es gab ja einige Firmen, die angefangen haben, selbst nach Bugs zu suchen. Und die haben halt gesehen, was das kostet. Und das ist nämlich substanzieller Aufwand. Das muss man mal sagen. Leute einzustellen, so ein Gehalt pro Jahr in der Branche fängt bei 100k an. Und das ist echt Geld. Und wenn man guckt, wie viel exploit eine Person pro Jahr finden kann, und dann guckt, was so ein Bug kostet, und dann zahlt man halt lieber für den Bug. So gingen dann diese Bug Bounty Programme los, weil das für das Unternehmen effizienter ist. Also Bug Bounty heißt das Unternehmen schreibt sozusagen Kopfgeld auf Bugs aus, und wenn man einen schönen Bug findet, dann kriegt man eben Geld dafür, dass man das Unternehmen mitteilt.
Ich denke aber, dass Bug Bounty erst nach dem Exploit getradet worden ist.
Ja natürlich, aber das ist ja auch...
Dann gab es halt Market-Pressure dafür.
Es gibt Markt, genau. Und plötzlich hast du auch intern eine Methode, das ist ja für Unternehmen immer schwierig, ausgaben zu rechtfertigen, wenn sie die nicht beziffern können. Für irgendwie PR oder Goodwill oder so, das ist immer schwierig. Und wenn man jetzt mit irgendwelchen Bugs kommt, wo dem überhaupt nicht argumentierbar ist, wo jetzt der Vorteil für das Unternehmen ist, wenn die gefixt werden, das ist halt scheiße. Aber wenn es extern irgendwie einen Preis pro Bug gibt, den man da in seine Gleichung einsetzen kann und eine Grafik machen kann und sehen kann, hör mal, so viel geben wir hier für Klopapier aus und so viel Bugs könnten wir fixen, wenn wir das auch für Bugs ausgeben, dann gibt es plötzlich einen Druck innerhalb der Unternehmen, auch mal irgendwie einfach ein paar Bugs zu kaufen. Und das ist einfach sehr kostengünstig, weil die ja immer noch nicht viel zahlen. Also so eine Bug-Bound, die jetzt googelt, ist gerade hochgegangen wieder. Aber das ist immer noch größtenordnung klein, vierstellig. Außer man hat einen wirklich unglaublichen Bug. Also da gibt es ausnahmen, aber...
Ja, und dann ist es ja natürlich auch so, dass wenn man einen unglaublich tollen Bug hat, für den Google richtig viel Geld auf den Tisch legen würde, dann würde die dunkle Seite natürlich auch unglaublich viel dafür auf den Tisch legen.
Das sollen wir vielleicht mal erwähnen. Wie viel Kohle fließt denn da für so einen Bug? Also jetzt sagen wir mal, Top-Klasse wäre irgendwie ein IP-Stamp-Problem.
Top-Klasse ist tatsächlich im Moment iPhone. Für iPhone wird glaube ich am meisten 250k, so was in der Größenordnung, lasse ich neulich.
Echt, weil es da so wenige gibt?
Naja, das Problem bei iPhone ist, dass die da tatsächlich so ein bisschen so ein Full-Disclosure-Issue haben, durch die J-Breaks.
Ach, die guten Exploits gehen immer für J-Breaks raus?
Sie haben dann halt irgendwie einen coolen Exploit und dann gibt es irgendwie einen J-Break, der public ist und da ist der Exploit verbrannt. Das ist halt irgendwie doof. Außerdem hat halt jeder, der irgendwie halbwegs ein Target ist, hat halt irgendwie so ein Homophon und naja, was... brauchen sie halt irgendwie auch was, womit sie darauf schießen können.
Das ist doch kein Homophon, das ist eine 4- bis 5-Sterne-Hotelfone, das hab ich gerade erst gelernt. Ja, also bisher hat man so gesagt, der Goldstandard ist irgendwie ein Remote-Exploit im IP-Stack von Windows. Dafür würde man, weiß ich nicht, halbe Millionen kriegen, also aber das gibt's halt nicht mehr, diese Art von Bugs, oder fast nicht mehr.
Naja, also ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ist das denn, was die anderen... Ich hab mir nur gemerkt, dass halt iPhone ist halt gerade top of the line.
Das sind ja auch Bugs, die es tatsächlich noch irgendwie in der Wildbahn gibt. Aber das war bei Stuxnet so eine Sache, die uns echt irritiert hat, dass sie da ein paar echt teure Exploits verbrannt haben.
Ja, da denke ich.
Und auch stabile Exploits. Also das sollten wir noch kurz erläutern. Exploit ist ja nicht gleich Exploit. Nehmen wir an, ich finde jetzt einen Bug. Die sind nicht alle so, dass ich da irgendwie ein bestimmtes Paketchen schicke und dann habe ich die Box geohnt, sondern inzwischen gibt es von den Herstellern Gegenmaßnahmen, deren Ziel nicht ist, den Exploit unmöglich zu machen, aber ihnen unstabil bzw. sehr teuer zu entwickeln zu machen.
Manchmal ist die Software auch einfach so scheiße, dass die Tiere schrumpfen, wenn du wirst.
Aber im Allgemeinen ist es so, dass, wenn du einen Bug gefunden hast, das ist ungefähr ein Zehntel des Aufwands oder noch weniger von dem Gesamtding, weil ein Exploit zu bauen einfach unglaublich schwierig ist.
Also einen stabilen Exploit.
Einen stabilen Exploit muss man vielleicht noch mal erläutern. Das heißt, dass der Code, der durch diese Schwachstelle injiziert wird oder zum Laufen gebracht wird, dass der tatsächlich unter fast allen Umständen auf den Angriffspartizip-Plattformen auch wirklich stabil läuft und nicht nur die Kiste zum abstausch bringt.
Genau, und wer mal irgendwie ein israelisches oder japanisches Windows in der Hand hatte, hat ungefähr eine Vorstellung davon. Also vielleicht zur Vorstellung für die Hörer, ein israelisches Windows ist tatsächlich von rechts nach links. Also da ist der Startbutton rechts und auch die Prozentbalken gehen irgendwie von rechts nach links. Und genauso sieht der Code auch aus.
Der geht auch von rechts nach links.
Also Exploits zu bauen ist nicht so schwierig, aber stabile Exploits zu bauen ist richtig scheiße schwierig. Und manchmal gibt es Bugs, die auch ohne Super-Exploits stabil nutzbar sind. Und davon haben sie halt ein, zwei bei Stuxnet verbrannt.
Na eigentlich drei davon sind hundertprozentig stabil.
Aber der eine war auf schnellere Versionen, das soll ich jetzt nicht dazu erzählen.
Nee, der ist nicht hundertprozentig.
Dieses Druckerteil war doch hundertprozentig?
Ja, das Druckerteil. Ja, aber der andere, der für die beiden Privilege Escalations für XP und die für Vista und Höher, die waren beide hundertprozentig. Der Prinz Buhler war hundertprozentig. Genau. Und der alte 09, da gab es einfach aus dem Metersploit so viele Targets, dass der schon fast hundertprozentig war.
Also gut, ich meine, bevor jetzt irgendwie unsere jungen Hörer und die kommen, hey cool, Viertelmillionen, da werde ich jetzt mal Bug-Researcher, sollten wir vielleicht noch dazu erwähnen, dass man für die allermeisten Sachen da draußen gibt es halt irgendwie nur ein paar hundert oder ein paar tausend. So weil es halt einfach so viel davon gibt.
Keine Sau interessiert sich für PAP-Explosionen.
Und dann sollte man vielleicht auch noch, gerade was diese Bug-Markets angeht, da gibt es ja diese hunderttausende, die bekommt man ja auf eher so Schwarzmarkt. Also da hat man ja dann schon mit Unterhändlern zu tun, die das dann irgendwo hin noch weiter verkaufen an Dollargeheimdienst oder Militär oder so. Und das kommt ja mit ein paar Viertelfüßen. Also erst mal ist es ja so, man baut schon, also wenn man das wirklich kann und eine Weile gemacht hat, ist man nach aussage von Dave I Tell, Immunity, ist man ungefähr 500 Mannstunden an so einem Ding dran. Wenn in der Zwischenzeit jemand diesen Bug findet und fixt oder publiziert, ist man im Arsch. Das heißt, es ist einfach schon mal rein als...
Als das erste Risiko.
Genau, davon lebe ich jetzt irgendwie keine besonders schlaue Nummer. Das nächste Ding ist, wenn man das weiter verkauft, dann muss man das natürlich exklusiv machen. Klar, also dann darf man das halt nicht noch jemand anders zeigen oder noch jemand anders geben, weil dann, wenn so geheimniedes Sauer auf einen ist, ist es halt immer nicht so lebenserwartungsfördernd.
So jetzt muss man aber sagen, wie funktioniert denn so ein Verkauf? Das ist doch das Problem. Wenn ich einen Exploit habe und ich will ihn jetzt dir verkaufen, dann willst du den natürlich sehen, weil ich kann ja viel behaupten, dass der stabil ist. Du willst ja sehen, dass der tut. So dann habe ich ihn dir gegeben und was jetzt das Schlimmste wäre, was du tun kannst, ist, dass du den weitergibst. Aber das kann ich ja nicht prüfen. Normalerweise, wenn ich irgendwie einen Bug an Google verrate und die fixen den dann, dann weiß ich, die haben ihn benutzt. Aber wenn du ihn an die Israelis verkaufst, da sehe ich ja nichts von. Weil die ganzen Händler und die ganzen Käufer von solchen Bugs veröffentlichen das ja nicht. Das heißt, hier gibt es ein Vertrauensverhältnis, wo ich als Verkäufer vom Bug immer der Gearschte bin.
Genau, was noch viel schlimmer ist, wenn du ihn verkauft hast, du hast exklusivität garantiert. Jemand anders findet das Ding oder macht deine Büchse auf und kopiert ihn von deiner Büchse runter, packt den irgendwo hin, dann denkt irgendwie Dollar-Geheimdienst, an den du das vertickt hast, irgendwie, du hast sie beschissen und zack hast du die wieder am Hals. Zur Krönung kommt drauf, zumindest in Deutschland kommst du dafür in Knast 202c.
Wir haben ja......
Also du darfst in Deutschland einver-... Das Ding ist, die kaufen, so Google oder so, die Bugbaue und die Programme, die kaufen Bugs. Das ist die Vulnerability an sich. Da muss man keinen Exploit für schreiben.
Vollkommen legal.
Die Geheimdienste und die Militärs kaufen Exploits. Die brauchen das fertige Angriffstool. Und das ist 100% illegal in Deutschland.
Und das ist vor allem viel schwerer, als nur den Bug zu finden. Wobei die Bugbauern die Programme auch gerne einen Exploit sehen wollen. Also da muss man schon, wenn du da die Elite-Summe haben willst und nicht nur irgendwie die 3,50 Dollar-Dacke für die Teilnahmesumme, dann wollen die schon auch einen Exploit sehen. Und der aktuelle Trend ist, dass man mehr als einen Bug ausnutzt, um irgendwie einen stabilen Exploit hinzukriegen. Google hat gerade ein paar Details veröffentlicht, die waren spannend. Der eine Typ hat, ich glaube, 14 Bugs ausnutzen müssen, um aus Chrom nicht nur einen Chrom anzugreifen, sondern aus der Sandbox auszubrechen. Also das heißt, selbst wenn ich jetzt einen tollen Bug gefunden habe, heißt das nicht, dass es reicht, um damit einen schönen Exploit zu bauen. Also man hat einen immensen Aufwand, der total schaden werden kann, wenn jemand anders den zentralen Bug findet oder auch nur einen von denen und fixt. Dann hat man verloren. Wenn der Unterhändler einen bescheißt, hat man verloren. Und die Isolation zu dem Geheimdienst, das ist ja eine der Ideen, warum es überhaupt Unterhändler gibt, ist, dass der Geheimdienst nicht weiß, von wem der Bug kommt. Die ist halt auch, im Grunde kann es sich nicht darauf verlassen, im Zweifelsfall.
Genau.
Warum verkauft man denn jetzt nicht direkt an die Geheimdienste, wenn man eh gearscht ist?
Keine Ahnung.
Also ich habe versucht, das auszufinden, habe mit ein paar Leuten geredet, die da ihren Lebensunterhalt mit bestreiten. Und die eine Antwort war, wenn man sich auf die jetzt mit Geheimdiensten einlässt, dass die dann eben so Nebenwirkungen haben, wie du darfst das Land nicht mehr verlassen.
Du weißt dann zu viel.
Du weißt zu viel, genau. Dann kriegst du irgendwie ein Clearance-Level und dann wirst du am Flughafen aufgehalten und du musst vorher angemeldet haben und dich begleitet dann jemand von der Botschaft. Also jetzt nicht ganz so krass, aber nach Saudi-Arabien-Reisen zum Beispiel ist da nicht mehr. So, wenn man ein Ami ist. Und das andere Problem ist, dass man überhaupt nicht weiß, wie man da ansprechen soll in den Diensten. Also das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Das wissen, je nachdem, mit welchem Dienst man zu tun hat, auch die Dienste selber nicht.
Na gut, ich hab das jetzt nicht probiert.
Obendrein bleibt natürlich noch einfach irgendwie die Frage, die ich auch sehr spannend finde, ist, warum sollte man das eigentlich tun, als ich meine außer-aus-geld-gear?
Nein, Moment, also es gibt ja noch einen Aspekt. Es gibt auch Firmen, die sich tatsächlich darauf spezialisiert haben, Bugs zu finden. Also zumindest eine ist relativ bekannt in der Szene, Franzosen wuppen. Ob das jetzt ein tolles Geschäftsmodell ist oder nicht, von außen immer schwer zu beurteilen. Die Positionen gehen da auseinander. Aber es ist also nicht völlig unmöglich, damit Geld zu verdienen. Ich kenne persönlich, ich glaube, drei Leute, die ihren Lebensunterhalt damit bestreiten oder mal bestritten haben, zumindest für eine Weile. Besonders wenn man noch mittelloser Student ist, kann man das rechtfertigen, den Zeitaufwand.
Ich finde das nicht zu rechtfertigen. Nein, also rein ökonomisch meine ich jetzt. Auch als mittelloser Student exploits an schattigen Mitteln meiner zu verkaufen, wo ich nicht weiß, wo die dann landen. Weil die Frage zum Beispiel, an wen verkaufen die denn? Also woher weiß ich zum Beispiel, dass der Mittelsmann, selbst wenn ich jetzt gerade mal patriotischer Amerikaner bin und sage, okay, ich verkaufe halt irgendwie an eine Firma, von der ich weiß, dass sie an die CIA weiterverkauft. Es gibt ja solche Leute, die irgendwie der Meinung sind, dass sowas okay ist. Woher weiß ich denn, dass diese Firma dann nicht oder auch die CIA, die nicht keine Ahnung an Saudi-Arabien weiterverkauft.
Da kannst du mal von ausgehen.
So, das heißt also klar ist halt, was man da tut ist, man baut halt Waffen und gibt sie halt aus der Hand an die Leute, die sie am wenigsten Skrupel haben, sie einzusetzen. Genau. Und insofern...
Und es ist tatsächlich auch nach, wenn ich mich nochmal auf Definition umreiten darf, es ist tatsächlich auch nach internationaler Definition eine Waffe. Also Waffe ist halt definiert als ein Gegenstand, die genutzt werden kann, um Lebewesen in seiner physischen oder psychischen Handlungsfähigkeit zu beeinträchtigen, zu verletzen oder zu töten. Und damit ist der Bug keine Waffe, aber der exploit definitiv.
justin Bieber ist eine Waffe.
Also insofern ist halt der, also wenn man halt irgendwie versucht mit so etwas Geld zu verdienen, dann sollte man sich halt schon tunigst auf die, auf die Bug-Mod, die Programme der Hersteller zurückziehen. Gibt es denn eigentlich Firmen, die, also was weiß ich, irgendwie diese Tipping-Point-Leute zum Beispiel, die einem garantieren, dass sie nur an die Hersteller verkaufen?
Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht.
Na ja, Papi ist geduldig, du kannst ja nicht irgendetwas nachweichen.
Nee, klar, gut, aber ich meine, der Punkt ist halt, also genau diese Frage, wie sich nicht mit diesem nervigen Hersteller auseinanderzusetzen, trotzdem Geld dafür zu bekommen, ist ja schon durchaus eine attraktive Proposition.
Es gab neulich einen sehr witzigen Blogpost von einem Typ, der hat, glaube ich, einen Black Hat Talk auch daraus gemacht, wie man ein Bug-Bounty-Programm ausnutzt oder so. Und der hat halt geschrieben, dass er bei Google immer darauf guckt, wann die wieder in eine Firma kaufen, weil Googles Bug-Bounty-Programm beinhaltet eben ausdrücklich alle Produkte von ihnen. Und wenn die gerade eine Firma neu kaufen, dann ist deren Produktportfolio von einem Tag auf den nächsten eben Teil im Soft Target. Das ist halt üblicherweise beschissenste Code-Qualität. Irgendwelche Start-ups haben ja andere Probleme als auf Produktqualität zu achten. So das ist halt heutzutage alles just in time. Sobald der Updater geht, schiebt man es. Und da kann man eben das Bug-Bounty-Programm nutzen, um dann eben das gezielt anzugreifen. Und da kann man tatsächlich von leben.
Also das ist jetzt kein schöner Job, aber ich finde das durchaus irgendwie legitim.
Äthisch noch vertretbar. Jedenfalls deutlich mehr als irgendwelche Dienste da zu befeuern.
Gibt es große Unterschiede zwischen den einzelnen Ländern, die ich immer sehr faszinierend finde? Also wie die Hacker in den einzelnen Ländern damit umgehen. Also mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist eigentlich immer irgendwie Frankreich, wo ich immer den Eindruck hatte, dass das schon immer so war, wenn du irgendwas kannst, dann bist du entweder kriminell oder arbeitest für Regierung oder Waffenbauer oder beides.
Das ist ja auch tatsächlich.
Also was anderes gibt es da gar nicht. Und es ist sehr lustig, mit Managern aus Frankreich zu reden, die dann immer überhaupt nicht verstehen, warum sie jetzt irgendwie einen Deutsch-Zweisteller aufgemacht haben und das irgendwie seit Jahren nicht performt. Weil wir hier einfach eine ganz andere Kultur haben, wo wir uns halt eher dagegen wehren, so was zu machen. Bei den Amis hat sich, das finde ich total faszinierend, hat sich irgendwie in den letzten 15 Jahren einmal 180 Grad gedreht. Also da war es, um Jeff Moss zu zitieren, der Gründer von BlackHat und Defcon, der meinte mal vor ein paar Jahren, naja, so vor zehn Jahren warst du der Idiot, wenn du für die Regierung gearbeitet hast. Und heute bist du der Idiot, wenn du nicht für die Regierung gearbeitet bist. Also da gab es halt den kompletten Switch.
Aber wir können vielleicht erzählen, bei der Defcon gab es immer so einen In-Joke, Spot the Fed.
Ja, das gibt es auch immer noch.
Aber es ist halt jetzt doppelt ironisch.
Ist jetzt eigentlich total.
Heute ist das sinnlos. Aber früher war das eben so, dass man sagen konnte, der Typ, den ich da hier, ich zeige jetzt einen Typ, den zerre ich vorne auf die Bühne und behaupte, der ist ein Undercover-Mitarbeiter bei irgendwelchen Regierungsinstitutionen. Und dann musste er sagen, ja, ich bin ein Fed oder nein, ich bin kein Fed. Und wenn er zugibt, für die Regierung zu arbeiten, dann gibt es ein T-Shirt für beide. Das war immer so der In-Joke. Also da ging es halt so um die Abwehr quasi von Regierungsunterwanderung. Wir haben so etwas beim CCC ja auch gehabt vor vielen Jahren. Ich erinnere mich, es war ganz witzig, da haben wir nämlich immer vorne rechts in der ersten Reihe so ein paar ältere Herren Anzügen gehabt, die sich versucht haben, in unser Publikum einzublenden. Das merken die, die die ganzen langehaarigen Hippie-Hacker mit ihrer dicken Tüte in der Hand unternehmen, halt diese älteren Herren. Das war aber ganz witzig.
Irgendwann haben für diese Leute dann spezielle braune Badges gehabt.
Tja, also dieses Problem gibt es natürlich schon länger, dass die natürlich auch wissen wollen, wie das alles funktioniert und dann kommen sie halt zu hackern. Und heute ist das so, dass in Amerika gibt es auch einen Anreiz dafür, ein wirtschaftliches Anreiz, nämlich, dass die Uni-Besuche richtig Asche kosten. Sowas von irgendwie 20k im Quartal ist da durchaus normal. Und das hat man eben nicht. Und dann kann man sich entweder bis über beide Ohren verschulden. Student Loans, das ist so das übliche Modell. Das kann man sich aber auch nur leisten, wenn man nicht auch ein haus haben will. Und das alternative Modell ist, dass man sich eben verpflichtet für irgendwie FBI, CIA, NSA, blablabla, irgendwie Militär. Und dafür zahlen die einem dann die Uni. Aber man muss irgendwie fünf Jahre seines Lebens da verbringen. Deswegen ist es durchaus häufig bei irgendwelchen Hightech-Dingern, wo die uni-ausbildung besonders teuer ist, dass die eben alle mal ein paar Jahre ihres Lebens beim Militär verbracht haben als Hacker. Das gibt es bei uns so nicht. Und ich glaube, das ist auch einer der Hauptgründe, warum wir weniger Militärhacker haben als die Amerikaner.
Ich meine, die Bundeswehr versucht es ja natürlich. Also der eben genau auch mit diesem quasi demselben Prinzip. Also das ist halt irgendwie auf...
Universität der Bundeswehr.
Naja, die sind ja so schlecht nicht, was irgendwie die technischen Sparten angeht. Aber die lassen dich ja auch durchaus auf normalen Unis studieren. Also sie finanzieren dir halt das Studium und nicht so schlecht. Dafür, dass du dann halt ein paar Jahre dazubringst. Und da gibt es halt durchaus auch Leute, die jetzt machen sie die Bundeswehr. Hat ja am Anfang durchaus erhebliche Probleme, überhaupt Leute zu finden, die ja für ihre Cyber, wie heißen sie, Computer-Netzwerkooperationen?
Wenigstens sagen sie nicht Cyber. Also ich fände ja, dass William Gibson der Einzige ist, der Cyber sagt, darf man. Genau, ohne blöd auszusehen.
Korrekt. Das können wir eigentlich als Tagline für die Sendung nehmen werden. Naja, gut, aber die Frage ist natürlich, also es werden halt tonnenweise Bugs gefunden, weil irgendwie jeden Tag genügend neue Bugs in Software geschrieben werden und irgendwie in Großteil von Leuten auch ausnutzbar sein. Aber was tun wir denn jetzt? Also ich meine, das ist ja irgendwie kein dauerzustand. Also ich meine, das muss ja irgendwie behoben werden so.
Naja, die traurige Realität ist, wir wissen nicht, was man da tut. Wir haben seit 20, 30, 40 Jahren versucht, Bugs zu fixen. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. Deswegen haben die Firmen heutzutage angefangen, Sandboxing und Mitigations zu machen, statt die Bugs tatsächlich zu fixen.
Ja, und ich denke, die Frage ist jetzt eigentlich nicht, irgendwie werden wir die Bugs los, weil das wissen wir alle, wissen wir gerade nicht. Die Frage ist halt, wie gehen wir mit der Exploitation, also genau der ausnutzung im internationalen Raum um. Also gegen den Fakt, dass wenn ich ein hinreichend kompliziertes Stück Computer habe, Telefon reicht schon, dass jemand, der ein bisschen Ahnung hat und genügend Motivation und Zeit da reinkommt, gegen den werden wir ein absehbares Ufer nichts machen können.
Aber es gibt doch jetzt Sandboxes.
Moment, das ist ja... Maaaan, das ist mein Joke.
Oh, bitte.
Also generell das einzige, was wir wirklich...
Du weißt warum die so heißen, ne? Weil nur Kinder daran glauben.
Das eigentliche...
Und das BSI.
Sagt er doch schon. Also der eigentliche Feind ist Komplexität. Das ist einfach eine Sache, die man lernen kann, die ist seit vielen, vielen Jahren bekannt. Seit eine IBM-Mitarbeiterin Mithi Kilmann-Manz geschrieben hat, ist das bekannt. Spätestens seitdem gibt es keine ausrede mehr. Aber das ist eben nicht, wie Software funktioniert, wie internationale Standards funktionieren. Bei Gesetzen ist das ja auch so. Die alles, sobald irgendwas eine gewisse Komplexität erreicht, gibt es eben Mittel und Wege, das auszunutzen. Die ganze Steuerhindertziehungsscheiße, das ist ja irgendwie dasselbe Problem. Das werden wir auch nicht los, außer wir machen das alles einfacher. Und das ist eben kein Weg, den keiner gehen will, weil wenn es einfach ist, dann ist es ja leicht kopierbar und unser proprietärer Vorteil gegenüber der Konkurrenz ist ja, dass wir so toll sind, so komplex und das kann die einer nachbauen und deswegen haben wir da eben dieses Problem. Und der eine Ansatz war einfach, bug-baut die Programme, Geld dafür auszugeben, dass Bugs gefunden werden. Das funktioniert auch halbwegs, aber es lässt nicht nach. Also die Hoffnung, wenn man so ein Programm macht, ist ja, dass man am Anfang viel findet und es wird dann immer weniger, weil die Bugs einfach alle werden, aber das ist einfach nicht. Das kann man in der Statistik klar sehen. Das passiert nicht.
Na, das hängt davon ab. Also ich meine, es gibt ja Gegenbeispiele, ne? Allerdings waren das keine Bug-Bounty-Programme. Warum ist Apache irgendwie so selten, dass es da gute O-Days für gibt oder Open SSH? Das hat zwei Gründe.
Keiner will mit Tier oder Rat zu tun haben.
Apache ist einfach in den 90ern schon, wo die Hacker sich noch größtenteils gegenseitig hochgenommen haben, so was von Tod auditiert worden. Da haben so viele Millionen Eyeballs drauf geglotzt und versucht dann noch die letzten Memory Corruptions rauszuholen. Und das Apache-Team war auf der anderen Seite natürlich ganz clever, gesagt, ne, den Webzopfer fassen wir nicht mehr an, da brauchen wir nur noch Bugfixes. Das heißt, die Komplexität nicht hochschrauben.
Na gut, dafür greifst du jetzt die Java-Mittel-Ware an.
Ja klar, das reicht sauber durch, aber der Apache bleibt am Leben. Aber das zeigt schon, man kann tatsächlich mit dem Vorgang an sich sichere Software erreichen, nur lohnt sich das halt für irgendwen, der dann mit der Software Geld verdient, lohnt sich das nicht.
Was uns ja theoretisch wurscht sein kann, so lange wir uns auf freie Software beschränken. Aber da ist es eben auch so, dass die Scheiße immer komplexer wird. Es gab gerade von linus, dem Kopf hinter Linux, gab es gerade so ein tolles Langley-Interview, das er gegeben hat, der hat einen Preis in Finnland gekriegt, wo er meinte, naja, die Komplexität vom Linux-Körner ist jetzt auch so groß, dass es kein Einzelner mehr durchblickt und er schläft nachts nicht gut, wenn er daran denkt, dass eines Tages ein Bug kommt, den keiner mehr blickt, was jetzt eigentlich das Problem ist, weil einfach diese ganzen interagierenden...
Was meint ihr, mit eines Tages benutzt ihr das noch?
Ja, nee, also inzwischen, normalerweise, naja, so üblicherweise, sie haben halt Support in ihr versionigen System eingebaut, um Schuldige zu finden, wenn irgendein Bug bekannt wird. Und das hat bisher gut geholfen, aber die Gesamtkomplexität des Systems, ich meine, das sagt ja einiges aus über die Komplexität, wenn du Softwarehilfe brauchst, um einen Bug einzugrenzen, weil du das nicht mehr als Mensch blicken kannst.
Aber ich meine, gerade bei Linux-Körne und dem Drumherum ist es ja genau das, was bei LPG richtig gemacht wurde. Wir fassen es nicht mehr an, sobald es mal läuft und fixen halt nur noch die Bugs und alles andere, bleibt einfach so, wie es ist, egal ob wir es jetzt schön finden oder nicht. Das ist ja bei Linux echt nicht so. Also ich meine, denk mal irgendwie an Dev-File-System oder sowas. Jedes Mal, wenn es dein Linux-Update ist, kriegst du Neues. Wenn du so elementare Systemkomponenten alle fünf Minuten änderst, weil wieder der nächste Projekt-Menthainer reinkam und dachte neue Besen und ich mach's jetzt mal anders. Genau.
Genau, noch mal schreibt. Naja, aber gut, ich meine, wir stellen also fest, die Situation wird nicht besser. Gut, Mitigation-Ansätze.
Erklären wir mal, was eine Mitigation ist.
Genau, also Mitigation bedeutet, man kann das Problem nicht irgendwie lösen, weil die Software ist halt zu komplex und da gibt's halt lauter Bugs drinnen. Also versucht man, es irgendwie einzusperren. Also dafür zu sorgen, dass irgendwie, wenn da drin irgendwas anbrennt, nicht gleich die ganze Hütte runter brennt, sondern heute nur der eine Raum.
Also Mitigation ist eher so eine Sache, das ist Sandboxing, was du gerade beschreibst.
Ja gut, das Sandboxing ist halt eine Mitigation-Rechte.
Genau, Mitigation ist weitgehender. Mitigation ist auch zum Beispiel so was wie, dass man das Memory-Layout hin und her schiebt, sodass, wenn man denselben Prozess dreimal startet, dass dann alle Sachen jeweils einer anderen Adresse sind. Und das heißt, dass man im Exploit nicht mehr sich verlassen kann darauf, dass an dieser Stelle das ist. Und dann macht es halt die Sache komplexer, sondern so einen ausnutzen. Es gibt immer noch Mittel und Wege, aber das ist halt einer der Wege, wie man das schwieriger macht. Und früher hat man eben den Chartcode einfach auf einen Stack getan. Das geht auch nicht mehr, der ist nicht mehr ausführbar inzwischen. Also das sind Mitigations, dass man sagt, man bekämpft eben nicht den Bugs, sondern wie der Bug ausgenutzt wird, versucht man schwieriger zu machen. Und das funktioniert leidlich, muss man wirklich sagen. Ich war eigentlich immer dagegen, muss jetzt sozusagen meinen Hut fressen hier. Mein Argument war immer, dass wenn man Mitigations einführt, es ist eben a, zusätzliche Komplexität, da können Fehler drin sein, und b, der Aufwand, den ich da reinstecke, den kann ich halt nicht in das Finden von Bugs investieren.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber schon so, dass natürlich irgendwie gerade so Execution Prevention zum Beispiel, dass man bestimmte Speicherbereiche einfach nicht executable macht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Idee.
So oder halt irgendwie oder...
Aber wo hörst du auf? Ja, das ist halt immer, also wenn man jetzt sich die Windows, nur so die Windows-Architektur anguckt, wie viel Versuche die unternommen haben, Sandboxing zu machen und irgendwie ihren Prozess-Tokens noch irgendwelche Einschränkungen aufzuerlegen, seit Jahren ist das ein Ding und nie ist es wirklich zufriedenstellend und wir brauchen noch eine Iteration. Aber wo man sich das mal angucken kann, dass das tatsächlich funktioniert, ist Chrome. Chrome hat die beschissenste Render-Engine von allen. Es sind mehr Bugs in Chrome pro Monat als in Firefox im halben Jahr. Aber in Chrome sind die halt in der Sandbox drin und es gibt nicht viele, die aus der Sandbox ausbrechen können. Das heißt, unter dem Strich ist Chrome vergleichbar sicher, obwohl die Render-Engine-Qualität deutlich schlechter ist.
Ja, aber gerade bei Browsern ist diese sandbox-diskussion eigentlich ganz spannend. Nehmen wir doch mal ein Chromebook, so diese Google-Variante. Das Ding ist ja nur dafür da, deinen Browser auszuführen. Das heißt, alles, was den Angreifer eigentlich interessiert, dem Angreifer, klar, historisch sind wir es gewöhnt, dass wir uns eine Root-Shell holen oder eine System-Shell und dann die ganze Kiste. Aber was den Angreifer eigentlich interessiert, sind ja deine Daten. So, und jetzt hast du irgendwie eine Büchse, wo alles schön zugenagelt ist, der Renderprozess auch schön irgendwie sicher ist und so. Und der hat alle deine Daten in der Hand, weil das Einzige, was du auf dem Ding benutzen kannst, ist der Browser. Insofern hat dir der Sandbox überhaupt nichts gebracht. Das ist genauso wie diese Nummer, was manche Leute so erzählen. Virtualisierung macht ja alles sicher, weil die Virtualisierung ist ja dann meine Sandbox. Mir ist es doch wurscht, ob die Kiste, die ich hochgenommen habe, eine virtuelle oder eine physische ist, solange ich die Daten daraus tragen kann.
Genau, das ist der Nachteil.
Ich muss noch kurz erklären. Also die Sicherheitsphilosophie-Idee dahinter ist ja, dass man sagt, okay, man macht nicht alles in derselben Sandbox und man handhabt irgendwie die kritischen Daten, also die jetzt halt irgendwie, was weiß ich, irgendwie das Online-Banking oder was auch immer, in einem anderen Browser-Fenster zum Beispiel, also in einem anderen Sandbox-Compartment, als da, wo man halt irgendwie auf, wie in Vienfels, solchen Pornseiten surft.
So ist es aber nicht, weil du nämlich zentral die Cookies verwaltest, wo da ein Zugriffstoken drin ist.
Genau, also das Problem liegt halt daran, dass eben genau diese Idee dahinter ist halt irgendwie so eine grüne Tischidee, also dass man halt einfach voraussetzt, dass die Leute halt irgendwie ihren sicheren Browser und ihren unsicheren Browser haben und dass sie irgendwie auseinanderhalten könnten, was jetzt was ist und warum irgendwie was funktioniert. Also dass das irgendwie, also das...
Gibt's ja auch bei den Amis irgendwie diverse... Also das ist halt auch so ein schlimmer Effekt an diesem ganzen Cyberwar-Hype, dass irgendwie jede Einrichtung, die irgendwie an Funding hängt, also die von anderen Leuten, die machen jetzt Cyber, egal ob sie davon Ahnung haben oder nicht. Oder es gibt unzählige Projekte, die alle gleich aussehen, egal ob das jetzt auf dem Telefon ist oder auf einem PC oder so, wo du dann halt zwei Desktops hast. Der eine hat einen roten Hintergrund, der andere hat einen grünen Hintergrund und da kannst du zwischendrin umschalten und mit dem roten darfst du in das böse Internet und mit dem grünen darfst du in dein Geheimnetzwerk.
Das sind einfach die alten Metriken, das sind die einzigen Metriken, die wir im Grunde haben. Das sind irgendwelche Zugriffmodelle aus den 70s für das Pentagon. Also ursprünglich hat das Internet auch vorgesehen, dass ein Paketheader drinsteht, das ist jetzt ein vertrauliches Paket. Und das ist ein normales Paket. Und diese Idee hinter Virtualisierung ist, dass man die trusted computing base minimieren will. Das ist so ein Konzept aus der Informatik. Da geht es eben darum, dass der Teil, dem ich trauen muss, und wenn ich den Browser in eine Sandbox tue, dann muss ich dem halt nicht mehr trauen. aus Sicht des Betriebssystems. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass der nicht trotzdem zugeworfen alle Daten hat, die für den Angreifer wichtig sind. Und das ist eben das Problem, dass man erst gute Metriken braucht, bevor man anfängt, Software so zu optimieren, dass sie den Metriken genügt. Das geschieht halt nicht.
Also einer der großen Freunde von Sandboxing und Virtualisierung ist ja unser Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Dann bleibt ihm noch anderem übrig.
Ja, wahrscheinlich eben mangels anderer Dinge. Da müssen wir vielleicht kurz drüber reden, gerade in diesem Kontext mit Bundeswehr und Computer-Netzwerk-Operationen. Also das BSI ist ja in Deutschland eigentlich dafür zuständig, für die Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik zu sorgen. Aber da sie ja nun frequent die Einzigen sind, die so einigermaßen Ahnung haben von dem, was sie tun. Also zumindest gibt es ein paar Leute, die so sind. Doch, ein paar gibt es.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Das ist ja dann natürlich die interessante Frage, die auch zum Beispiel beim Staatsteuern ja hochkam. Warum hat denn nicht das BSI den Staatsteuern geordnet und dafür gesorgt, dass es halt irgendwie nicht scheiße ist?
Das habe ich mal nachgeguckt. Das war eine interessante Frage. Da habe ich mal nachgeschaut, das dürfen die nicht. Und zwar ist relativ klar irgendwie das BSI, da gibt es ein BSI-Gesetz. 2009 gab es auch eine Novelle. Und das BSI darf nur Verhinderung von Angriffen und Statistik machen. Das heißt selbst, wenn es gibt zum Beispiel Paragraph 3, Absatz 13 oder Punkt 13, da ist dann die Unterstützung von anderen Behörden geregelt. Also BND, Verfassungsschutz, Polizei sind explizit erwähnt, dass da spezielle Unterstützungsleistungen laufen können, nur für die Verhinderung von Angriffen. Das heißt, denen ist es gesetzlich nicht gestattet, irgendwas, was wir, Offensive Security, also sprich Angriffe zu machen, überhaupt zu behandeln. Das ist nicht anfassend.
Das lustige daran war, dass irgendwie zumindest im Bundestag, also in der CDU-Fraktion, Das war der Vorschlag von dir. kursiert er ja die andere, denn dazu die interessante Ansicht zu sagen, naja, da es ja bei dem Staatstrojaner unter anderem darum ging, sicherzustellen, dass nicht ein Dritter diese staatliche Maßnahme angreifen kann, können wir das BSD über diesen Umweg dazu zu kriegen, zumindest die Krypto- und die Command- und Control-Stelle zu zertifizieren.
Naja, so das war halt so der, es ist nur so gerade der standardliche.
Momentan ist es total theoretisch, weil irgendwie ist BKA sowieso irgendwie nicht in der Lage ist, so was zu schreiben. Aber zumindest fand ich das eine interessante Interpretation der Gesetzeslage.
Ich meine, du musst dir dann auch noch natürlich überlegen, irgendwie du hast dann ein haus voller Überzeugungstäter, die versuchen irgendwie den ganzen Schadsoftware-Kram mal ein bisschen einzudämmen. Die haben natürlich auch mal noch eine ganz eigene Meinung dazu, was sie jetzt sinnvollerweise da machen oder lassen sollten. Also aber die können sich halt wirklich sehr, sehr schön auf das BSI-Gesetz zurückziehen. Also es geht ja sogar so weit, dass in dem Gesetz sozusagen Full Disclosure geregelt ist. Das wusste ich auch nicht. Ich hab das echt noch mal nachgelesen, finde das total super. Die dürfen Bugs nicht behalten. Die müssen, also in dem Gesetz ist tatsächlich der Responsible Disclosure Prozess, den wir alle kennen, erst mal mit dem Hersteller reden, fixen lassen und dann die Informationen an die Öffentlichkeit geben, ist in diesem Gesetz vorgeschrieben. Das heißt, die dürfen nicht mal Bugs für sich behalten.
Okay, cool die Scheiße.
Das heißt, da müssen wir nur noch die dazu bringen, dass die Bug-Bounty machen und dann haben wir alle unseren Lebensunterhalt gesichert.
Also wer es nachlesen will, Paragraph 7 vom BSI-Gesetz 2009er Version.
Coole Scheiße.
Okay, das wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht. Gut, ich meine, okay, dann bleibt ja sozusagen unsere Bundeswehr. Die Bundeswehr lässt sich ja...
Die könnte das mit ihrer umfassenden Cyberwar-Kompetenz...
Also gut, die Bundeswehr ist gerade dabei, ihre Computer-Netzwerke-Operations aufzubauen, seit irgendwie zwei, drei Jahren oder so.
Viele haben doch gesagt, sie sind jetzt startbereit.
Sind sie wohl startbereit, sondern wir haben ja mal so ein bisschen rumgehäucht, so wo die jetzt irgendwie ihr Wissen hier haben. Und stellt sich raus, dass es da irgendwie so den Bombenbauerteil von Frauenhofers gibt, die unter anderem sich über Netzwerksicherheit kümmern und da wohl halt irgendwie Kurse gemacht haben. Also da haben wohl einige Akademiker dann doch ihre Seele verkauft.
Also was ich bei der NATO hörte, war, dass die Bundeswehr tatsächlich, sie wären jetzt so weit, dass sie simulierte Red Team Veranstaltungen machen. Also sprich, die sitzen immer noch irgendwie in ihrem kleinen Kapuff und spielen mit virtuellen Maschinen.
Na ja, gut, ich meine, das ist interessant.
Na, immerhin. Das ist schon mehr, als ich gedacht hätte, ehrlich gesagt.
Tun sie da schon mal was. Aber die spannende Frage ist ja, unter welchen Bedingungen könnten sie dann eigentlich überhaupt was tun? Weil ich meine, also die Frage ist, wie sieht die Doktrin für so eine Netzwerkeingriffe eigentlich aus? So und das ist ja eine Frage, die ja, also wenn wir ein bisschen mehr zurück auf die Metaebene kommen, die Frage, wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, ist eine kriegerische Handlung oder ist zumindest eine Konflikthandlung, dann ist ja die Frage, okay, dafür gibt es in Deutschland einen klaren Parlamentsvorbehalt. Also eigentlich.
Ja, nee, es ist ja eben keine Konflikthandlung. Es fällt unter ein Konflikt. Ja, aber es fällt unter ein bewaffneter Konflikt. Ist ja was anderes als Konflikt. Es fällt unter die Regeln von Krieg und bewaffneten Konflikt, wenn sowieso schon einer am Start ist. Also du musst schon vorher rumballern, damit das damit runterfällt. Wie das außerhalb von der Kriegssituation ist, hängt halt gerade tierisch in der Luft. Man sagt halt, also viele Argumentationen sind, naja, das ist dann halt normale Geheimdienstoperation. Und das ist ja im Völkerrecht so geregelt, so zwischen Völkern darfste, ja. Also keiner darf dich angreifen, weil du ihm Spionen geschickt hast. Aber in deinem eigenen Land läuft das dann nach deinem eigenen Recht. Das heißt, es ist in den meisten Ländern auch relativ in Ordnung, irgendwie Spione einfach wegzusperren, ohne irgendwie einen Richter zu fragen oder zu erschießen. Oder zu erschießen, zu hängen vom Land ab.
Und gerade von den Umständen.
Das hilft natürlich nicht viel, wenn es eine Spionage Software ist.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal hypothetisch an, irgendwie unsere Bundeswehr ist in der Lage, irgendwie ihre, keine Ahnung, 80 Leute, oder was sie da jetzt haben, die irgendwie für Komputer-Netzwerk-Operationen ausgebildet sind, tatsächlich einzusetzen. Und die wären jetzt in der Lage, irgendwie andere Leute dazu aufzumachen und da tatsächlich auch Dinge zu bewirken. Die Frage ist, unter welchen voraussetzungen dürfen sie das eigentlich?
Also solange sie nicht den status eines Geheimdienstes, ich meine, du kannst ja auch im Militär auch Geheimdienst, ne?
Dann kommen eine strategische Aufklärung zum Beispiel.
Solange die nicht irgendwie einen geheimdienststatus haben, dürfen sie das meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Weil es dann eine militärische Operation wäre für diese in den Parlamentsverbehalt bräuchten. Genau. Was uns dann zu dieser interessanten Frage bringt, irgendwie wie sieht denn überhaupt eigentlich so der, also wie sieht denn so eine militärische Strategie im digitalen Raum aus? Das ist halt eine nicht-unspannende Frage. Also früher gab es halt so klare strategische Dogmen, halt sowas wie die gegenseitig gesicherte Zerstörung, also Digital Destruction, die halt das Fundament der nuklearen Abschreckung bildete. Also halt beide Seiten haben genug Atomwaffen, um den Arm einfach zu verdampfen und daraus resultiert halt irgendwie die Idee, okay, dann tut man halt nichts. Was de facto passiert war, dass irgendwie beide Seiten, also die russen und die Amerikaner, über Proxies, also halt über irgendwelche Gröser-Streitkräfte, kleine Stammhütze gebracht haben, eben sich trotzdem bekriegt haben, aber eben in einer Art und Weise, die halt sozusagen unterhalb der Schwerteres Nuklear-Ankonflikt blieb. Und nun ist die Frage halt, wie sieht sowas halt irgendwie im digitalen Raum aus? Und da ist eines der großen Probleme, man weiß ja nicht, von wem so ein Angriff kam. Also bei Stuxnet zum Beispiel war es ja auch so, dass wir uns zwar zusammenreimen konnten, wer es jetzt wahrscheinlich gewesen ist. Sehr schnell. Gegen wen es ging, war einigermaßen klar, nachdem halt irgendwie der Code von dieser Payload, also die halt die Zentrifugenz zu vibrieren brachte, analysiert war. Und auch klar war, um welcher Art von industriesterrung es ging, nämlich halt um Motorcontroller, die für hohe Rotationsgeschwindigkeiten ausgelegt sind. Aber wer es dann halt war, da konnte man dann nur so ein Cubono fahren. Also wem nutzt es, um zu sagen, okay, waren dann wohl die Amerikaner oder die Israelis. In anderen Fällen ist halt die Sache sehr viel schwammiger. Also schon Flame ist halt ja so in der Kategorie so, naja, könnte man irgendwie aufgrund dessen, dass es Ähnlichkeiten zu stuchsen hat, gibt es halt irgendwie.
Hätten sie vielleicht nicht dieselben Module reinbauen sollen?
So achter Jahr.
Aber jetzt kommt die spannende Frage. Also eine Abschreckungslogik gibt es ja unter den Gesichtspunkten einer der Abwesenheit von eindeutiger Attribution nicht. Also wenn man es drauf anlegt, es nicht attributierbar zu machen, dann nimmt man sich halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, einen Server von russland oder China und greift von da aus die Briten an.
Ja, aber das ist auch disputable.
Also erst mal, selbst wenn es von dir kam, kannst du ja auch sagen, du bist von Chinesen gehackt worden.
Genau.
Na klar, aber Attributierbarkeit ist eben das Problem.
Ja, aber nun, jetzt nehmen wir mal an, die Amis kommen und sagen, stuchsen etwa an wir. Kann der Iran jetzt nicht irgendwie was tun?
Genau. Also ganz, ganz schöne Story. Diese Attribution-Frage geht da natürlich auch irgendwie groß rum, gerade im internationalen Recht. Und ich fragte dann so ein paar Juristen, wie das denn aussieht, ob denn jetzt nicht der Iran einfach mal da hergehen könnte und vom internationalen Gerichtshof in Den Haag irgendwie die Amis und die Israelis verklagen würde, wo die sich tierisch gefreut haben, weil die meinten, ja, das können die auf jeden Fall machen. Und da hätten wir auch endlich mal ein Case. Problem ist, in der ReaWorld wird das nicht funktionieren, weil schon, wenn du den Case da einreichst, sagen die, ja, aber ihr haltet euch ja auch an 500 Resolutionen nicht.
Ist kein ausschussgrund.
Ist kein ausschussgrund, aber deswegen...
Die Amis sind doch keine Signatoren, also es geht nur gegen Israel, oder? Haben die Israelis und die Israelis beim internationalen...
Nee, ach Quatsch.
Wir sollten so auf die Idee kommen.
Na gut, aber dann hast du ja eh verloren, dann kannst du das auch nicht mehr machen.
Ja, der Punkt ist, verurteilen können sie sich trotzdem.
Ja, aber ich mein, das ist halt wie ein Warme-Endendruck.
Strongly worded letter ist und man jetzt hier was sagt.
Aber die interessante Frage ist ja eben, dass sie es zugegeben haben, also dass sie gesagt haben, okay, also per Leak halt, aber gesagt haben, okay, Stucks sind zwar von uns und demzufolge Flame auch, erzeugt ja eine strategisch interessante Implikation. Nämlich dadurch ist halt klar, okay, sie haben gezeigt, was ihre Capabilities quasi waren vor drei Jahren, als sie das Ding geschrieben haben. Die sind einigermaßen impressive, also gerade in Flame halt irgendwie die Md5-Collision so, ist halt schon nicht irgendwie was, was man mal eben bei macht. Das war halt schon so...
kompograferauspack.
Also halt so dick heiß war technisch, war das halt schon irgendwie so Tung so. Und dadurch entsteht so eine Situation...
Na das ist doch dasselbe wie mit Nuklearkrieg, oder?
Moment, warte mal, lass mich mal ausreden. Was da entsteht, ist eine ähnliche Situation wie mit dieser israelischen Nuklearambigity. Weil die Israelis, alle wissen, dass die Israelis Atomwaffen haben. Die Israelis geben es nicht zu. Und daraus folgt, die Doktrin unter der sie diese Atomwaffen einsetzen, ist vollständig unklar. Niemand weiß, wann die Israelis tatsächlich, also was für die Israelis die Red Line ist, wo sie mit Atomwaffen zurück schlagen würden. Und genauso ist es halt ebenso so, dass bei den Amis und ebenso auch bei den Israelis, eben dadurch, dass sie jetzt gezeigt haben, was die Capabilities sind, also in welcher Größenordnung sie planen und wie viel Geld sie ausgeben und wie viel Personal sie da drauf werfen und wie viel es ihnen wert ist, dass sie das jetzt einmal gezeigt und sozusagen auch belegt haben, entsteht jetzt die Situation, dass da sitzt halt jemand, von dem ist halt einigermaßen klar, dass er so ein paar große Keulen im Schrank hat. Aber und es ist auch einigermaßen klar, dass er die auf so relativ kleinen Anlässen auch irgendwie rausholt.
Und die Frage, ja, also relativ, das ist ja nun umstritten, oder? Wie klein der Anlass tatsächlich ist.
Na ja, gut, ich meine, dass Iran halt irgendwie sich eine Atombombe bauen will. Weiß ich nicht, also...
Na ja, das ist schon nachvollziehbar, dass Israel sich da...
Gut, ja, aber... Also ich meine, das ist halt...
Na, wieso?
Ich meine, also Israel hat... Also gerade bei Stuxnet ist ja so, dass Israel den deutlich höheren Aufwand getrieben hat, ne? Weil klar, Stuxnet an sich war irgendwie ein fettes Stück Angriffskur, auf jeden Fall, aber der Riesenaufwand, gerade praktisch an Natur war die Beschaffung von den P1-Zentrifugen. Die haben ja ein komplettes Test-Bed aufgebaut. Und überhaupt die Dinger mal zu beschaffen, war wohl extrem aufwendig, weil irgendwie alter russenschrott irgendwie schwer zu beschaffen. Ja, hatten halt... Iraner hatten halt welche, die konnten sich schlecht fragen, weil die brauchten die selber. Und dann...
Pakistan hatte welche.
Die hatten halt noch irgendwo, keine Ahnung, wo sie die dann hergekappt haben.
Also die Karn, die Zwerg offen waren.
Und die... Also die Gerüchte gehen dahin, dass die Israelis irgendwie ein Jahr oder zwei gebraucht haben, die Dinger ans Laufen zu kriegen, damit sie nämlich endlich die Drehzahlen rausfinden, die sie fahren müssen, damit es dann schief geht, ohne dass die Dinger ihnen um die Ohren fliegen. Also die Israelis haben da schon mehr Aufwand getrieben als die Amis tatsächlich.
Okay, aber das heißt ja eben, dass strategisch man jetzt in den Schulen von Iran oder russland oder China ist, da muss ich mir halt überlegen, was tue ich denn, also welche Erwartungen habe ich, wann die so was einsetzen und unter welchen Umständen. Als Putin würde ich mir jetzt gerade schon Sorgen machen.
Aber das ist doch genau wie, nachdem die Amis die Atommobil zum ersten Mal eingesetzt haben.
Ich würde dir zeigen, was sie damit geschaffen haben.
Aber da ist ja nichts ambigius dran. Wenn du sie da einmal eingesetzt hast, dann hast du auf dem Tisch gegangen.
Na ja, aber deine Doktrin ist halt unklar.
Ja natürlich, aber das war bei den Amis auch der Fall.
Ja, aber das ist ja genau bei den Israeli auch der Fall.
Ja, natürlich. Der Teil stelle ich dir auch zu.
Dieser Bigotty besteht halt eben darin, dass das unklar ist, unter welchen Umständen und unter welchen Bedingungen so ein Einsatz erfolgt und mit welchen Mitteln dahinter.
Na ja, eine Baseline haben wir jetzt, ne?
Und daraus folgt halt irgendwie natürlich, dass es eben plötzlich doch so was wie Abschreckung geben kann, was wir halt eben aufgrund dieses Attribution-Problems ja eigentlich eher ausgeschlossen haben. In meiner eher der Ansicht zu, mangelst Attribution wird halt irgendwie so ein Abschreckungsding schwierig, aber dadurch, dass sie jetzt zugegeben haben, dass sie das halt irgendwie sieht waren, haben sie das halt so ein bisschen durchbrochen.
Naja, also auf diese Attribution, dass die nicht so einfach ist, möchte ich mal eingehen, weil da gibt es ja verschiedene Stufen. Also was will ich für eine Attribution? Will ich eine Attribution, die irgendwie von einem internationalen Gerichtshof hält? Das wird schwierig, weil kann immer jemand sagen, ja scheiße, ich war auch geohnt. Will ich eine Attribution, die, zum Beispiel eine technische Attribution, also woran lag es denn, dass wir irgendwie alle, damit ein bisschen ausgehen und Code lesen können und sowas, auf die Stuxnet-Nummer geguckt haben und gesagt haben, ja, made in, alles klar. Technische Attribution halte ich für deutlich einfacher. Und das, was immer behauptet wird, also ich hörte neulich, dass die Briten behaupten, dass wenn sie irgendwie so Angriffe bauen, also GCHQ macht das ja bei denen, dass sie über 80 Prozent der Zeit in dem Angriff verwenden für Storybuilding. Das heißt, sie bauen den so, dass es aussieht als KMS von den Chinesen oder sowas. Das halte ich für absoluten Bullshit, weil wenn ich eine Angriffe so bauen kann, dass er eine perfekte Story ist, dann könnte ich auch sichere Software schreiben. Und dann würde ich beim GCHQ kündigen und reich werden. Also wir wissen alle, wie schwierig das ist, die Software überhaupt halbwegs sinnvoll hinzubekommen. Gerade wenn es um so einen High-Profile-Angriff geht. Dann ist es auch noch irgendwie so zu verwursten, dass ich da lauter jenisische Zeichen drin hab und so was. Halt ich für mumpitz. Das heißt, ich finde ja, dass wir in der Zukunft sehen werden, dass viel mehr und mehr evidence-based gemacht wird. Also dass man sich, man denke an die, an so Kleinigkeiten, wie wir in der Kriminaltechnik heutzutage haben. Vor 100 Jahren gab es noch keine DNA-Tests. Da haben wir Fingerabdrücke nur mal so über den Daumen gepayelt und so. Heutzutage ist das ja alles sehr viel detaillierter. Kennt jeder aus CSI. So, das haben wir natürlich bei Computerangriffen noch lange nicht. Moment, glotzt mal einfach drauf und so, ja, hat funktioniert. Wer könnte denn? Aber das wird sicherlich kommen, weil denselben Compiler auf zwei verschiedenen Windows verschiedener Sprache laufen lassen, kommt ziemlich sicher nicht der gleiche Code raus.
Na ja, also wir haben es schon, aber wir haben es nicht systematisiert.
Wir haben es nicht systematisiert. Das ist halt so ein bisschen wissen, was jeder so ein bisschen mit sich rumschleppt, der sich damit ein bisschen auseinandergesetzt hat. Aber es ist halt nicht systematisiert. Das heißt, ich denke, in absehbarer Zukunft ist technische Attribution zumindest so weit möglich, dass man sagen kann, das war dieselbe Gruppe.
Also eine Art Fingerprinting.
Dass du so eine Art Fingerprinting hast. Es wird schon seit, also ich glaube, schon ein Jahrzehnt lang irgendwie gemunkelt, dass die NSA mal so ein Programm hatte, wo sie Exploits nach Style zugeordnet haben. Das funktionierte witzigerweise 2000, 2003 rum. Sehr geil mit den chinesischen Exploits. Es gab so eine Welle von Exploits, die von einer chinesischen Hackergruppe namens nsfocus kamen. Die hat man immer daran erkannt, dass sie immer dieselbe Technik für Code Execution, die haben so bestimmte SE-Hardchain-Override-Technik genommen. Und es war halt echt zu Exploit kriegen, also auch so im Binary, du wirst hochgenommen, nimmst dir das Ding, guckst rein, so chinesen, alles klar, so weiter. Das war so erkennbar. Und daraufhin hat wohl die NSA mal so ein Programm losgetreten.
Na gut, aber der nächste Schritt wäre doch dann tatsächlich Office Cache und Demo, indem ich dann halt eine bekannte Technik einer anderen Gruppe verwende.
Richtig, aber das glaubwürdig zu faken, ist halt genau wie ein Tatort glaubwürdig faken. Das kann ja halt auch schnell auf die Füße fallen. Aber das wollte ich nur zu dem Thema Attribution sagen, dass es dann ein weiteres Spektrum gibt. Für einen Verteidiger zum Beispiel reicht es mir völlig, wenn ich irgendwie die Taktiken wiedererkenne. Weil dann kann ich meine Netzwerkverteidigung entsprechend anpassen. Das macht heutzutage keiner, aber das ist eigentlich, was ich haben will.
Bei Stuxnet ist ja wohl einer reingelaufen mit einem USB-Stick. Da kannst du auch dein Netzwerk verteidigen, bis du blau anläufst.
Na ja, doch.
Da kannst du ein USB ausmachen.
Na ja, vor allem kannst du mal irgendwie die Sachen intern ein bisschen separieren. Außen hart und innen chewy ist halt...
Dann ist das doch unser traditionelles Modell.
Perimetersicherheit, ja.
Okay, also du meinst, dass das Attribution-Problem zumindest operational, also jetzt nicht juristisch betrachtet, sondern aus der Sicht von jemand, der einfach nur ungefähr wissen muss, wo der Kram herkommt, schon mit entsprechendem Aufwand zumindest nicht lösbar, aber doch zumindest angehbar wäre.
Ja, deswegen glaube ich auch, dass es keine Systematisierung geben wird. Denn wenn es die gäbe, wüsste es hätte sie ein Ziel, was du faken musst. Wenn es eine systematische Liste gäbe von Indizien.
Die willst du natürlich für dich behalten. Ja, natürlich, aber ich meine, die ist für dich denn auch ein Template, wenn du deine eigenen Sachen baust. Du willst schon allein deswegen klassifizieren können, damit du deine eigenen Sachen, wenn du den Aufwand treiben möchtest, dass du zumindest ein paar Red Herrings reinhängen kannst.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, wie sinnvoll das ist. Aber natürlich ja lieber investieren, dass das Ding sich selbst anständig vernichtet.
Naja, aber das ist ja wie...
Das ist schon mal aus Sportsgeisten.
aus Sportsgeisten? Na klar, aber als tatsächlich Budget-Posten, kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen.
Aber das ist ja wie in einer normalen militärischen Verteidigung.
Also ich meine, in einer normalen militärischen Forschung zum Beispiel, so ein typisches Skunkworks-Projekt, also wenn sie halt irgendwie eine neue bewaffnete Stealth-Drohne bauen, die irgendwie hyperscheif liegt oder so.
Haben die auch eine UFO-Story im Hintergrund?
Dann kalkulieren sie bis zu 40 Prozent des Projektbudgets für Tarnstories und irgendwie sagen... What?
40 Prozent?
Und zwar deswegen, weil sie dann teilweise Sachen irgendwie Aufträge an Supplier rausgeben, die total Bullshit sind, aber zu einer plausiblen anderen Story passen, zusammen mit den anderen Teilen, die sie ordern und so eine Sache.
Was für ein Mund ist das ja unglaublich.
Also insofern wirklich jetzt mal nicht komplett verwerfen die Idee, dass irgendwie zumindest in absehbarer Zeit jemand auf die Idee kommt zu sagen, okay, dann baut man es halt so, dass es halt zumindest irgendwie auf den ersten Blick so aussieht, als wenn es halt irgendwie aus einer bekannten Ecke kommt oder in einen Non-Profile matcht.
Krass, das ist scheiße.
Ja, und du möchtest natürlich auch das vermeiern, die Leute gerade im militärischen Umfeld gerade richtig großflächig, egal ob es um Angriffserkennung von eigenen Angriffen geht oder um tatsächliche Netzverteidigung. Die denken halt genau so systematisch, statisch. Das ist halt so, wir bauen uns da jetzt mal irgendwie folgende gelben Büchsen von dem Sicherheitshersteller hin und dann ist alles gut. Es ist immer total großartig, sie zu fragen. Ja, sind ja nun mal alle Leute mit einer militärausbildung. Wie oft sie denn so im Feld, wenn dann Nacht kommt, irgendwie Nachtlager aufschlagen, Zornen drumrum machen und dann gehen alle schlafen. Gucken sie einen blöd an und sagen, ne, da muss doch einer Wache schieben. Ja, und was mit euren Netzen? Da schiebt keiner Wache.
Dann haben wir doch eine Kamera.
Ja, wir haben auch eine Überwachungskamera, ein IPS.
Ja, solange du berechenbar bist, kannst du natürlich gefaked werden.
Ich mach das ja bei Kunden immer, wenn wir da irgendwas penntesten wollen, frage ich die dann auch immer, ob sie das jetzt gesehen haben in ihrem Angriffssäckchen.
Und wie ist die Quote?
Noch nie. Natürlich nicht, ist ja auch Bullshit. Alles Schlangenöl.
Ich meine, wenn man das halt mal so versucht, so ein bisschen zu klassifizieren, kann man denn schon Unterschiede in den Strategien der einzelnen Länder erkennen?
Na ja, man kann andere Einstellungsstrategien erkennen. Also wie die ihre Leute rekrutieren, das kann man durchaus auseinanderhalten. Also wir haben die Geschichte der Amerikaner haben wir schon angerissen vorhin.
Bei den Israelis ist es halt so, dass die halt systematisch gucken nach irgendwie die Rekruten, weil das ja Zwangsarmeedienst heißt, also die haben halt einmal die gesamte Jugend in einem bestimmten Alter.
Wohlgemerkt auch für Frauen.
Auch für Frauen. Haben sie halt alle in ihren musterungssystemen und die gucken halt offensichtlich da schon nach irgendwie Hacker-Mindset.
Wer den Computer bedienen kann, wird rausgefiltert und zwar sofort.
Da gibt es halt eben entsprechende Einheiten, also z.B. halt so diese IDF Unit 9000 ist halt so eine relativ bekannte Electronic Warfare-Einheit, deren Mitglieder sich dann hinterher lustigerweise irgendwie meistens in den Boards von irgendwelchen Start-ups finden. Wenn sie da fertig sind, die kennen sich dann hinterher eben doch alle. Und da kommen dann halt irgendwie so bekannte...
Das ist halt ja noch eine andere Dimension, oder?
Bekannte Firmen für irgendwie die...
Abrechnung von Telefondaten.
Oder Abrechnung von Telefondaten raus. Also die...
Remote Maintenance.
Großzügig dimensionierter Fernwartungsdienststelle.
Und da die Israelis machen es halt sehr systematisch, halt so ihre Strategien und dementsprechend haben die halt auch einen relativ guten Ruf, was irgendwie so deren Offensivkapazitäten angeht, kann denen wohl so schnell niemand etwas erreichen. Zumindest nicht für die Größe ihrer Ressourcen. So bei den Amis, na gut, die erschlagen es offensichtlich wie immer mit Geld.
Ja, die kaufen halt im freien Markt das Ami- und das kapitalistische Modell.
Die typische Ami-Lösung kann man mit Geld erschießen.
Ja, Dump.
Ich hörte mal den ausdruck Money-Hose.
Ja, genau, das ist ein mythisches Instrument der DARPA, wo sie ihre Money-Hose hinlenken.
Gut, bei den russen ist es ein bisschen unklar. Da ist es bekannt, dass die relativ viele Freiwillige haben. Also die Angriffe auf die Ästen und so.
Wie war das mit der Putin-Jugend? Diese Angriffe auf die Ästen, das ist ja auch so eine Geschichte. Das wird ja immer so gerne als irgendwie Die First Cyberwar hochgehalten. Wenn man sich mal anguckt, was da so gelaufen ist, das kann eigentlich auch eine gut organisierte Achtmann-Hacker-Truppe einfach so aus Spaß gemacht haben.
Ja, das hat sich nicht wirklich von dem bewegen, was so ein typisches anonymous-kiddie-kollektiv an einem gelangweilten Nachmittag verursacht hat.
Genau so sieht das nämlich aus. Ich finde das sehr lustig, weil gerade auf diesen Konferenzen, wo sowas diskutiert wird, die plappern alle denselben Blödsinn nach. Da hat sich keiner mal wirklich angeguckt, was da überhaupt gelaufen ist. Für die ist das, das war Cyberwar. Deswegen sprechen sie auch nur im Kontext von den russen, von irregulären Truppen. Das finde ich sehr, sehr lustig. Diese Terminologie der irregulären Truppen im Cyberwar wird nur in diesem Kontext russland gegen Estern verwendet. Das ist so... Freischärfler.
Das ist natürlich... Oh Gott, was für ein Unsinn. Also was wir von den russen auch noch wissen, ist, dass der FAPSI, deren NSA-Äquivalent ist, was Personal- und finanzielle ausstattung angeht, durchaus äquivalent zu dem, was die NSA da so treibt. Sind halt ein bisschen weniger bekannt, aber man muss nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen, dass sie angesichts der guten Fähigkeiten der Sowjetinnen und später russlands gute Mathematiker rechtzeitig früh zu erkennen und auszusieben und irgendwie in entsprechenden Dienste zu führen, kann man wohl schon davon ausgehen, dass die irgendwie relativ viel können.
Das ist ja ein gutes Zeichen, es gibt ja diesen alten Witz, der beste Geheimdienst der Welt ist der von den Dänen. So, warum, da hast du schon mal von der Opposition gehört, die so gut sind, die Spieler. Ja, also das ist ja in sich ein gutes Zeichen, dass man von den russen wenig hört an der Stelle.
Und also man hört immer nur so, wenn halt irgendwie so ihr Verfassungsschutz und so halt irgendwie wieder mal vor den Gefahren von eintronischer Spionage warnen, dass sie dann halt irgendwie vor den russischen Geheimdiensten halt irgendwie besonders warnen.
Also die richtig advanced Geschichten werden auch von den Leuten, die sich tatsächlich angeguckt haben und nicht irgendwas nachgeplappert, werden tatsächlich auch zu den russen so hingedichtet. Ja, in einigen Fällen kommt wieder diese Netzwerk-Attribution. Ja, bloß weil der Traffic dahin fließt, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass die da sitzen. Aber die die Dinger, die so richtig tief waren, da war es halt einfach auffällig, dass die Empfängerserver halt tatsächlich alle beiden russen standen.
Okay, die machen sich da nicht die Mühe, irgendwo anders was zu mieten, offenbar. Verstehe. So sieht es aus.
Zumindest den Eindruck hinterlässt.
Nach dem Wort in your face, weil ihr könnt sowieso nicht studieren.
Ja, und ich muss mal sagen, das wäre mir nicht nur sympathisch, sondern würde auch einfach irgendwie zu meinem Bild von so, wie russen sowas machen würden. Weißt du, wenn es aufgefallen ist, ist es doch eigentlich auch egal, wenn ihr seht, wer es war.
Klar, ich meine, es spielt natürlich auch wieder in diese freiwillige Attribution-Strategie rein.
Ich denke schon, also was du vorhin schon angedeutet hast, ich denke schon, dass das bei den großen Playern, also die großen Player sind immer Israel, Amis, russen, Chinesen, dass da im Moment so ein bisschen vorsichtig Karten auf den Tisch legen oder zumindest mal ins Blatt schauen lassen, zur Strategie gehört.
Also um zu so einer Abstracke zurückzukommen, ja?
Einerseits, das waren natürlich die Leute, die das entscheiden, alle Cold War Hintergrund haben, also noch sozusagen in diesen denkmustern hängen. Auf der anderen Seite, gerade bei den Amis und den Israelis, sehe ich halt noch den Aspekt, dass die ja selbst am verwundbarsten sind. Also die Amis haben halt auf absehbare Zeit, gerade mit dem ganzen Privatsektor und so, keine Chance, eine wirklich solide Verteidigung hinzubauen. Das ist einfach nicht. Also ich meine, die Stromnetztechnologie ist echt schon fast dritte weltstatus.
Und zwar absichtlich, ist ja kein Zufall. Die Telcos auch im Übrigen.
Genau. Und was sollen die denn machen? Also eine Defense-Strategie ist absolut hoffnungslos. Das heißt, dieses vorsichtig mal durchblicken lassen, was man auf der offensiven Seite an Möglichkeiten hat.
Also dann machst du mich an, dann mach ich dich platt.
Genau.
Mal den Knüppel zeigen.
Das könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen. Das würde auch erklären, warum die russen so selten auffliegen. Und wenn sie auffliegen, dass sie da nicht so groß rumparlabern, weil die haben da einfach weniger Motivation. Die nutzen das halt viel stärker in einem Geheimdienstkontext, als in so einem offensiven Kontext, wo sie jemand anderes die Atomanlagen runterfahren wollen.
Die Chinesen ja auch, die sind ja auch eher...
Wie funktioniert das bei den Chinesen? Wie ist es bei den Amis und ISRA-IH?
Was man von den Chinesen weiß, ist, dass sie unmöglich ein Personal haben und dass sie halt offensichtlich auch in der Lage sind, mit freischaffenden Hackergruppen irgendwie eng zusammenzuarbeiten.
Also ich war ja da mal auf so einer Konferenz. Eine der ganz wenigen Situationen, wo Chinesen tatsächlich mal irgendwie ausländische Speaker eingeladen haben, war alles hoch obskur, also bis hin zu Abschiedsgeschenken, die auf einem Sockel massiv Metall sind. Und wenn man sich das Röntgengerät im Flughafen fährt, und man sieht, da ist es einfach nur ein schwarzer Kasten. Dann haben wir uns danach gefragt, was machen wir jetzt damit?
Da aufmachen natürlich.
Ich hab's erstmal weit weggestellt. Aber da gab es so ein paar Merkwürdigkeiten. Das eine war, es gab so Gäste, also es gab halt normale Konferenz-Teilnehmer, die da auch Eintritt gezahlt haben und so was. Und dann gab es halt irgendwie Leute von angeblich der lokalen Uni. Das waren auch recht junge Menschen. Und das war dann sehr interessant, weil ich habe einen durchaus technisch sehr anspruchsvollen Vortrag gehalten. Und Cisco Exploitation und so was. Und nach dem Vortrag kamen dann zwei sehr junge Frauen, also so Anfang 20, an, die dann gemeinsam an der englischen Frage gepuzzelt haben. Und ich dachte so, wow, die Frage stellst du nur, wenn du das mindestens schon fünf Jahre machst, weil in das Problem läuft du erst rein, wenn du den ganzen Rest wirklich durch exerziert hast. Also solche Sachen sind dann da vorgekommen. Und da erzählte dann auch, zum Glück vertragen die ja alle nicht so viel Alkohol, erzählte an, nämlich bei so einem Empfang, dass sie ein großes Problem hätten mit den Hackergruppen. Die sind wohl sehr lokal. Also es gibt dann halt pro Stadt eine. Und die bugeln auch so ein bisschen um die Aufmerksamkeit des Militärs. Also das ist ja bei den PLA irgendwie alles eins. Und das machen sie, indem sie sich gegenseitig angreifen. Was hoch illegal ist in dem Land. Also man muss dazu sagen, verhacken wird man in dem Land erschossen. Und die greifen sich dann halt gegenseitig an. Und weil das dann irgendwann nicht mehr geholfen hat, sollen sie wohl, das sagte halt der eine, der jetzt dazu übergegangen sei, die brechen dann in Militärsysteme ein und hinterlegen Beweise, dass es die andere Gruppe war, damit die ausgelöscht wird. Also da scheint es einen richtig schweren landesinternen, das kennt man ja von anderen Bereichen, dass die Chinesen ganz starke interne Konkurrenz haben und wirklich nur die Besten weiterkommen. Und das scheint es unter den Hackergruppen auch zu geben.
Krass, okay.
Also das ist natürlich ein ziemlich solider Assortierprozess.
robust, sagen wir mal.
Na gut, die Frage ist ja dann, wie positioniert sich so ein Land? Wir hören ja offensichtlich die großen Player, oder zumindest nicht landgroß, aber zumindest stark investierten Player, fahren ja offensichtlich alle erst mal derzeit eine massive Offensivstrategie. Also alle versuchen sich irgendwie aufzurüsten.
Das ist auch ein Verstand der Forschung. Also Angriffstechnologie ist einfach mal fast eine Dekade weiter als Verteidigungstechnologie.
Ja, aber die Frage ist natürlich irgendwie so, was tut man als Hacker? Will man da mitspielen? So ist es irgendwie, also wollen wir denn irgendwie die Waffenbauer werden für diese Leute?
Na Moment, einen Punkt haben wir noch. Also wir haben jetzt gehört, wie die Länder drauf sind, aber wie ist denn die NATO drauf? Das ist doch noch ein Punkt, der...
confused, glaube ich.
Nee, nee, nee, da gibt es einen wichtigen, erzähl doch mal.
Da gibt es, ja, da gibt es eine wichtige aussage, die nämlich sagt, irgendwie die NATO sagt, wir brauchen keine Offensivkräfte. Also maximal irgendwie so ein kleines Red Team, dass man mal guckt, ob unsere Verteidigung in Ordnung ist, also wo wir uns selber angreifen. Aber wir brauchen keine Offensivkräfte. Das ist auch die offizielle Position im Moment. Ich denke, das hat einen relativ klaren Hintergrund, weil die haben, glaube ich, ein großes Problem damit, dass jemand Chapter 5 aufruft, wenn er gehackt wird. Also Chapter 5 ist ja die Unterstützung der Bündnispartner.
Der Bündnisfall, der sogenannte?
Genau. Also sprich, einer ist im kriegsähnlichen zustand und dann geht's los. Und man hat ja auch so ein bisschen kleinere Bündnispartner und man hat halt großen Respekt davor, dass das nächste Mal, wenn fünf pöblige russische Hacker irgendwie in Estland DDoS spielen, dass die dann irgendwie den Bündnisfall ausrufen und dann alle dastehen und überlegen müssen, auf wen sie jetzt bomben. Und ich denke, deswegen hält man sich in der NATO da sehr, sehr stark zurück.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Aber ist das nur nach außen hin und intern haben sie aber schon was, oder ist das tatsächlich die, machen die das auch?
Also ich glaube, ich nehme das jetzt einfach mal als gegeben hin, weil wenn die NATO keine Offensivkräfte hat, hält das ja ein einzelnes Land nicht davon ab, sich selber welche zu bauen.
Dürfen wir sagen, wie das gesagt hat? Weil das ist ja durchaus ein höhere Offizieller.
Ja, das dürfen wir. Das kann ich euch auch sagen, weil das war glaube ich nicht, also das war offiziell von einem Mr. Wilhelmse, der für C4, also das ist Command, Control, Communication and Intelligence, zuständig ist bei der NATO. Allerdings jetzt gerade in den Ruhestand geht, also vielleicht sieht der nächste das anders.
Na gut, aber ich meine, es bringt uns jetzt zu der Frage zurück, wenn die NATO sagt, okay, wir brauchen keine Offensivkräfte, weil wir fürchten, dass es dann halt irgendwie relativ schnell irgendwie zu kinetischen Bombenwerfoperationen kommt, wenn wir halt irgendwie den Bündnisfuhr ausrufen. Wie verhalten wir uns als Hacker dazu? Also so, ich persönlich so finde ja so Waffenbauen, also als Offensivwaffenbauen halt irgendwie nicht unbedingt irgendwie so ein...
Gänzlich unakzeptabel. Na, aber wir sind ja sogar noch weiter als TCC. TCC haben wir ja eine Geschichte mit Geheimdienstkooperationen. Das ist dann auch immer voll in die Hose gegangen.
Vorhin gut erwähnt, so ja. Ist halt irgendwie so aus der Geschichtelernte, liegt dann halt auf jeden Fall nahe.
Und wir sagen ja auch nicht defensiv mit geheimdienstzusammenarbeit. Wir sagen ja gar nicht mit geheimdienstzusammenarbeiten. Und das ist nämlich gut gefahren mit bisher.
Na gut, aber trotzdem ist ja die Frage zum Beispiel, wir hatten ja gelegentlich diese diskussion jetzt auch jüngst wieder. Gehen wir zum Beispiel zu solchen Konferenzen, wie halt diese NATO-Konferenz da in Estland und reden wir mit den Leuten oder reden wir zum Beispiel mit der Bundeswehr über ihre komplette Netzwerkooperation und so ne Sachen. Und da gibt es ja ein durchaus nicht unbedingt einheitliches Meinungsbild. Ja. Also du vertrittst ja eher so die irgendwie so geht weg irgendwie mit euch, weil wir nix zu tun haben These.
Ja, na ich finde das generell, also ich sage man darf denen nicht helfen. Also ich finde man kann durchaus hingehen und hören, ja aber das werden die ja nicht wollen. Also ich meine, das Problem ist ja, die laden dich ja nur als Redner ein, du kommst ja nicht einfach als normales Publikum, bekommst du da nur, wenn überhaupt, gegen exorbitante Beträge rein.
Ja.
Das heißt, das Problem ist ja, dass die von dir erwarten, dass du dann dein Wissen mit ihnen teilst und das sehe ich halt überhaupt nicht ein. Ja, weil das sind Leute, deren Existenzberechtigung ist, dass sie anderen Leuten schaden wollen und solchen Leuten hilft man nicht, Punkt, ja das ist meine Einschätzung.
Aber es ist natürlich, ich sehe es ein, dass es ein verlust ist, wenn wir nicht wissen, was die tun. Also es ist durchaus schwierig, wie man da jetzt am besten.
Na, das ist die eine Seite und dann, also ich sehe das ja offensichtlich anders. Ich gehe auf solche Veranstaltungen. Weil wenn, also man muss es, man muss mal realisieren, die Leute, die da Entscheidungen treffen müssen. Also ja, das Thema ist nun mal da. Die können jetzt nicht vor dem Thema weglaufen. Die würden bei der baumhausregel failen. Man sagt ja baumhausregeln, wenn du zu alt bist, irgendwie mit reinzukommen, dann darfst du nicht mehr mitspielen. Wenn man die aufs Internet anlegen würde, dann wären die raus. Das Problem ist, die haben halt wirklich überhaupt keinen Plan. Und jetzt kommt dazu, dass sie gerade von allen möglichen Ecken und Enden mit Geld überschüttet werden. Mach mal Cyber. So, jetzt stehen sie da, haben irgendwie einen riesen Budget. Und natürlich, wie das ist, wenn du einen riesen Budget in der Hand hast, das ist genauso, als wenn du einen Goofladen in der Hand hast, dann kommen die ganzen Grünen fliegen. So, und da möchte ich mal irgendwie so ein paar Eckpunkte geben. Wer berät die denn im Moment? Also, wer sagt denen denn, wie das im Moment aussieht? Das ist natürlich zuallererst mal irgendwie die Lobby-Organisation.
Verlierer, können wir zusammenfassend sagen. Eigentlich alles Verlierer, die keine Ahnung haben.
Vorneweg zwei Firmen, HP Gary und Symantec, die wirklich auf jeder dieser Veranstaltungen rumspringen.
Ist das die HP Gary, die neulich von anonymous hochgenommen wurden?
Oder ist das die andere HP Gary? Die HP Gary fährt im Moment dieselbe Strategie wie Siemens. Wenn du öffentlich total auseinandergenommen wurdest, sagst du einfach, dass du jetzt das Unternehmen mit der größten Cybererfahrung bist. Das machen beide gerade. Also Siemens, wieso Bugs fixen, die rennen jetzt überall rum. Wir sind ja cybererfahren, weil Starksnet funktioniert ja so gut auf unserem Kram. So und bei HP Gary ist das ähnlich. Sie sind jetzt halt cybererfahren, weil sie ja von anonymous angegriffen wurden. Und Symantec ist natürlich der Riesenkonzern. Die rennen da halt wirklich nur rum und erklären, also geht schon mal damit los, dass die halt wirklich allen Politikern und Militärs erklären. Pass auf, das ist eigentlich genau dasselbe wie mit Viren, bei dir zu hause auf dem Rechner.
Kauft ihr unseren antivirus?
Deswegen, du hast ja unseren antivirus zu hause bei dir, deswegen ist ja da alles cool. Jetzt irgendwie kauf mal hier folgenden Scheiß im großen Stil für deine Regierungsnetze.
Symantik-Anti-Cyber, ja.
Aber hallo.
Was für eine tolle Idee.
Die erzählen, die können gar nicht schnell genug sich neuen Bullshit ausdenken, wie die Leute das kaufen. Und dann passieren solche Dinge, das muss ich jetzt einfach mal zum Besten geben. Bei so einer diskussion, wie man das so mit Legislation klären kann, ja also was können Länder dafür tun, dass sie sich selber besser absichern, damit wir dann in der europäischen Gemeinschaft zum Beispiel besser gesichert sind. Und da sagte ein Typ von einem europäischen Land auf einer Insel, was kein Euro hat, sagt, der da dafür verantwortlich ist, auch ein älterer Herr, naja das ist doch ganz klar irgendwie, das klären wir einfach mit den Firmen, die das Internet betreiben. Na ja, warte mal, dann gucken die sich alle an und ich dachte so, ich bin ja irgendwie der kleine Hacker, ich darf ja fragen, wer wäre das denn? Guck da mich an, als hätte ich so überhaupt keine Ahnung. Na ja, die vier Firmen. Welche vier? Na ja, das weiß man doch. Also Microsoft macht das Betriebssystem, Google macht die Suche, Facebook macht Social und Symantec macht Sicher. Wenn wir mit denen reden, ist alles geklärt. Und das ist das Level, auf dem die tatsächlich bilaterale, multilaterale Abkommen machen, auf denen die Gesetze beschließen und auf denen die entscheiden, wann für die NATO der Verteidigungsfall eintritt. Und da, finde ich, ist es durchaus hilfreich, denen mal zu erklären, vier reicht nicht. Da bist du ein bisschen falsch gewickelt. Also ja, weil auch, auch was, was aus der Academia-Seite kommt, für die ist es auch nur profitabel, mehr Angst zu machen und mehr auf die, auf Wire, wir werden alle sterben, Taste zu drücken, weil sie darüber dann Funding kriegen. Statt sich hinzusetzen und zu sagen, nee Leute, irgendwie ist alles nicht so einfach, wie ihr euch das vorstellt. Und so billig ist Cyberwar auch nicht. Haltet mal die Füße still und seht mal zu, dass ihr euer SAP-System ans Fliegen kriegt. Dafür, dafür haut niemand Academia-Funding raus.
Naja, also ich muss ja sagen, einen Satz, den ich immer sehr zutreffend fand und den ich auch gerne im Blog bringe, ist so, dass unsere beste Verteidigung gegen den Überwachungsstaat ist, dass die inkompetent sind. Und das finde ich eine gute Zielvorstellung auch. Und es freut mich zu hören, dass die so schlecht drauf sind. Und um mein Statement von vorhin ein bisschen zu relativieren, ich finde es auch durchaus in Ordnung, solchen Leuten Geld abzunehmen. Denn jeden Dollar, den die für Bullshit ausgeben, geben sie nicht für neue interkontinentale Raketen aus.
Ja, aber die Leute, die gut Bullshitten können, sind meistens die, die mit dem Geld nichts Sinnvolles anfangen.
Ja, das finde ich nicht schade. Finde ich besser für Bullshit ausgeben, was dann...
Naja, aber was ist denn mit der dritten Alternative, das Geld tatsächlich dafür auszugeben, wachslos zu werden und resilient Netze zu bauen?
Ja, aber das wird nicht stattfinden, das glaube ich nicht.
Na, das ist... Also ich finde die Reaktionen auf... Ich sage denen ja ziemlich deutlich ins Gesicht, dass sie keinen Plan haben. Und ich finde die Reaktionen darauf eigentlich ziemlich interessant.
Man erwartet ja rausgeschmissen zu werden?
Ja, genau. Neulich kam tatsächlich jemand, der in der EU dafür ziemlich zuständig ist. Auf mich zu, auch ein älterer Mann, meinte vielen, vielen Dank, dass da mal irgendwie technisch fundiert klare aussagen gefallen sind. Er wäre Physiker und ihm sei klar, dass die letzte fachliche Verbindung, die er zu meinem Bereich hätte, irgendwie das omische Gesetz ist. Weißt du, in jeder Organisation, wenn man lang genug sucht, findet man kompetente Leute. Auch in solchen Organisationen. Und sie haben tatsächlich einen Leidensdruck. Also da sind ja nicht nur Arschlöcher und Idioten unterwegs, sondern sind ja tatsächlich auch Menschen unterwegs, die für die Allgemeinheit und für das Volk irgendwie was Sinnvolles veranstalten wollen. Und die leiden einfach extrem darunter, dass sie nur mit Scheißbefolg geschmissen werden.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist ja ein natürlicher abwehrmechanismus. Das sichert das unser Überleben, wenn die alle ihr Geld in vernünftige Waffensysteme investieren.
Ich finde da noch einen weiteren Aspekt dabei nicht so schlecht. Und zwar also nicht unwichtig, nämlich gerade bei diesen ganzen Netzwerkangriffen und so weiter, insbesondere im militärischen Kontext, stellt sich ja schon die Frage, welche auswirkungen hat denn so was tatsächlich auf die Zivilgesellschaft? Und durchaus kann ich schon sehen, dass die Frage, Moment mal, wenn ihr jetzt anfängt, zivile Infrastrukturen anzugreifen, weil ihr irgendwie in ein Land runterfahren wollt oder weil ihr irgendwie ein Ziel erreichen wollt, wie verhält er sich das mit der Genfer Konvention, wie verhält er sich das mit den Menschenrechten, wie verhält er sich das mit den üblichen zivilen Rechten und den Einschätzungen dazu, dass die erst wirklich da reingekommen ist, nachdem Leute, wie wir gesagt haben, so Entschuldigung, Was ihr da gerade tut, hat halt irgendwie massiven Kollateralschaden und das könnt ihr nicht einfach so machen, nicht mal nach euren eigenen Regeln. So, was dann halt dazugeführt hat, dass jetzt irgendwie auf diesen Konferenzen halt eben auch tonnenweise Juristen rumlaufen und Leute, selbst Leute von irgendwie Menschenrechtsorganisationen, also zum Beispiel auch dieses ganze Randgebiet autonome Roboter, was ja sozusagen sich ja zu einem Teilzweig dieser ganzen Cyberwar-Geschichte entwickelt, dass da halt einfach die Perspektive der Zivilgesellschaft, wenn die da nicht präsentiert wird, also wenn da auf solchen Konferenzen nicht gesagt wird, so übrigens Entschuldigung, ihr habt da eine Konvention unterschrieben, dann fällt das halt auch unter den Tisch, dann wird das halt auch nicht wirklich bravsichtig.
Und zum Thema, mit euch reden wir nicht, also auf der letzten NATO-Veranstaltung, da waren natürlich auch Leute von Human Rights World. Die sehen nämlich genau diese Probleme auf die Zivilgesellschaften zukommen.
Hältst du das denn für realistisch, dass man die dazu bringt, dass sie in Defense investieren statt in Offense?
durchaus, ja. Das hängt einfach davon ab, wie Offense reguliert wird in der Zukunft. Also solange Offense in einem State ist, wie es jetzt ist, dass jeder irgendwie macht, was er für richtig hält. Und Wilder Westen ist ja nun mal einfach so, jeder gegen jeden, solange die damit spielen können, geht es nur um shiny new weapons. Klar, denn ja, man kauft immer im militärischen Sektor immer lieber Angriffswaffen als irgendwie als Defense-Geschichten.
Außer die Schweizer.
Wenn das reguliert ist, dann kriegst du automatisch auch die Defense. Also denk an andere Massenvernichtungswaffengeschichten, die reguliert wurden, dann in dem Moment, wo du nicht mehr beliebig in neue Waffen dieser Gattung investieren kannst, weil das schlicht und ergreifend irgendwie nicht mehr en vogue ist, kriegst du die Defense alleine deswegen, weil man jetzt sagt, okay, was machen wir denn, wenn sich einer nicht dran hält?
Na ja, die Frage, wie man so Waffen aus der Welt kriegt oder zumindest irgendwie reglementiert und dort eingeschränkt bekommt, stellte sich ja schon mehrfach an der Geschichte. Also da gibt es ja nun diverse Beispiele, wo es halt irgendwie trotzdem eigentlich als unmöglich galt, ist dann am Ende doch irgendwie gelungen, es zumindest irgendwie solche Waffen ein bisschen einzudämmen. Also chemische Waffen ist ein erfolgreiches Beispiel.
Genau, aber die sind Bio-Waffen auch.
Bio-Waffen auch.
Die sind auch inherent doof. Die haben irgendwie die Expire nach einer Weile und du hast sie.
Naja, trotzdem.
Aber wo ist denn jetzt der Unterschied zu Exploits? Also ich finde, Exploits haben, also gerade so die Cyberwaffen haben verdammt viel gemein mit Bio-Waffen. Das ist genau, oder mit chemischen. Du hast nämlich genau dieselben beschissenen Einsatzszenarien. Wenn der Wind in die falsche Richtung geht, bist du selber gearscht, ja? Das ist bei den Exploits genau dieselbe Nummer. Du hast die Eindämmungsproblematik. Du kannst nicht ohne Weiteres nur die Ziele treffen, die du haben willst. Oder nur mit Riesenaufwand. Du rennst nicht übers Schlachtfeld und spritzt den Leuten die Viren. Du schmeißt das halt in großem Stil ab. Das sind ja die Gründe, warum man sie nicht mehr haben wollte.
Stimmt, wenn wir diese Parallele ein bisschen gezogen kriegen, dass Cyberwarf wie Bio-Waffen ist.
Ich meine, es gibt einen inherenten Unterschied. Der besteht halt darin, dass momentan Netzeckangriffe noch ein eher cleanes Image haben und halt eher noch als eine gute Alternative. Also gerade Schluckshorn zum Beispiel.
Ja, doch frag mal die Iraner.
Eher gut, aber ich meine, Schluckshorn... Na ja, bloß selbst wenn man mal eine zynisch-objektive Perspektive einnimmt, dann war es besser, diese Zentrifugen fliegen in diesem Container einen Bunker durch die Gegend, als irgendjemand muss diesen Bunker aufbrechen und die ganze Scheiße fliegt in die Umgebung.
Ein bankarbuster.
Geflogen ist ja sowieso nix, die sind ja bloß langsamer und schneller gefahren.
Ja gut, bis die zerbrochen sind. Das reicht ja irgendwie. Insofern ist ja schon ein fundamentaler Unterschied zu Biowaffen. Da liegen dann hinterher nicht irgendwie fürchterlich entstellte Leichen auf dem Schlachtfeld rum, sondern nur in dem Bunker. Nur in dem Bunker, die sieht halt keiner.
Aber das ist eher ein Image als alles andere. Wir reden ja sozusagen von First-Generation-Cyberwaffe. Das kannst du eigentlich eher mit Clor im ersten Weltkrieg vergleichen. Man muss ja schon gucken, wie entwickelt sich das weiter. Und dann hast du halt genau diese Containment-Probleme, dass es dann zivile Infrastruktur mit hochnimmt.
Na gut, aber du hattest ja einen interessanten Vorschlag gemacht, wie man also einen ersten Schritt machen könnte, wie man dieses Attribution-Problem zum Beispiel umgehen könnte, mit dieser Analogie zum Umweltschutz.
Na es gibt verschiedene Sachen im internationalen Recht, die ich interessant finde. Eine, die wird tatsächlich noch gar nicht diskutiert, die ist mir aber neulich untergekommen bei den Satellitenleuten. Es gibt ja irgendwie die sogenannte Outer Space Treaty, also das Weltraumgesetz von 67. Und das habe ich mir in Vorbereitung auf diese Sendung mal ein bisschen angeguckt. Und das könnte man eigentlich relativ schön für ein Cyberspace verwenden. Also ja und für Leute, die das so nennen. Ich bin ja nun mal nicht Gibson. Der Punkt ist, das sind ein paar ganz einfache Regeln, die ich sehr schön finde. Also Erforschung und Nutzung des Weltraums ist zum Nutzen der ganzen Menschheit da. Kann man so erstmal denke ich ziemlich sauber auf das Internet übertragen. Jeder Staat darf mitspielen, auch sehr sinnvoll. Kein Staat darf sich irgendetwas aneignen oder Souveränität erklären, weder durch Besetzung noch durch andere Mitte.
Na zu spät oder?
Na ja.
Kann man aufs DNS gucken?
Gut, aber damit würdest du zum Beispiel solche diskussionen, ja, würdest du sofort, also dann würde zum Beispiel DNS sofort unter die UNO fallen. Fun fact dazu übrigens, im Weltraumgesetz gab es tatsächlich richtig Ärger wegen dem, wie haben sie es genannt? Ach ja, Lunar Flag Assembly, also diese, diese Ami-Flagge, die die Apollo Leute da auf den Mond gesteckt haben. Weil da ist denen dann danach aufgefallen, dass das ja aussehen könnte, als wenn sie da jetzt das Claim wollen. Und da hat tatsächlich Nixon ein eigenes Gesetz, nochmal 69, rausgebracht, wo dann der ganze Kongress unterschrieben hat, gesagt hat, das war nicht so gemeint, dass wir wollten bloß irgendwie unseren Erfolg zeigen. Super. Das hat ihn dann irgendwie hinterherleit. So, und dann kommen wir nämlich zu der ganzen Geschichte Waffen im Weltraum und die sind schlicht verboten. Also das heißt, Nuklearwaffen und alle Weapons of Mass Destruction dürfen nicht in den Weltraum. Und alle hundert Länder, die da unterschrieben haben, haben gesagt, machen wir nicht mit.
Das erinnert mich aber lustig an Ironsky. Hast du Ironsky gesehen?
Nee. lustig daran ist, dass man 2006 versucht hat, irgendwie das auf alle Waffen auszuweiten. Und die Amis waren dagegen. Ja, Überraschung. So, und dann haben sie halt noch so Punkte drin, die ich halt, und das ist nämlich ähnlich zu dem Umweltgesetz. Staaten sind verantwortlich für alle ihre staatlichen und nicht staatlichen Weltraumaktivitäten. Das heißt, in dem Fall hättest du nämlich auch das Attribution-Problem nicht und diese Freischärle-Problematik nicht. Also wenn aus deinem Land irgendwie Netzwerkangriffe kommen, dann ist das mal scheißegal, ob du das beauftragt hast oder ob das irgendwelche pöbelnden Hacker in deinem Land sind. Du bist jetzt erstmal dafür verantwortlich, dass es aufhört.
Na gut, das ist ja nicht nur positiv. Also das kann man auch als Vorwand nehmen für fettere Infrastrukturen.
Und die Staaten haften für alle Schäden.
Also das ist ja aus dem Umweltrecht.
Das ist beim Umweltrecht genauso.
Wenn du scheiße in den fluss laufen bist, bist du dafür verantwortlich, dass es aufhört.
Und wenn es aus deinem Land kommt, da ist es auch dreckig, ob das die Privatwirtschaft war oder ob du das wirklich beantragt hast. Als Abschließendes sage ich noch den Punkt Astronauts shall be regarded as envoys of mankind. Was glaube ich ein ziemlich anstrebenswerter status für Hacker im Internet wäre.
Genau, hier vertreten wir die Menschheit.
Es gibt natürlich ein paar ganz praktische Probleme. Also wenn halt irgendjemand anfängt zu sagen, okay, der Staat ist für das, was aus seinen Netzen kommt, ja, auf jeden Fall verantwortlich und schuldig, dann ist natürlich irgendwie die Einladung, da halt irgendwie so Great Firewalls und DPI und so weiter hochzuziehen, um halt im Zweifel in der Lage zu sein, dieser Verantwortung nachzukommen.
Ja, kann man argumentieren, ob man die nicht sowieso kriegt.
Aber das kann ja nicht nur ein Vorwand geben.
Außerdem gibt es ja, naja, man muss beachten, dass internationales Recht halt viel, viel flexibler ist, auch in der, ich sag mal, Schuldigsprechung, quote unquote, als nationales Recht. Also im Strafrecht muss zweifelsfrei nachgewiesen werden, dass du das jetzt warst, sonst in dubio pro reo so bist du frei. Beim internationalen Recht gab es zum Beispiel, lernte ich die, gibt es ganz softe Abstufungen von Kontroll. Also wie viel Kontrolle, was ist Kontrolle, die eine Regierung irgendwo ausübt? Und da gab es so den softesten Fall als die, auch im Iran, die Studenten oder wo man sagte, es waren Studenten, in dann Ami-Botschaftsmitglieder irgendwie gekidnappt haben oder als Geise genommen haben. Da hat der Internationalgerichtshof wohl gesagt, dass allein die Duldung schon Kontroll der Regierung über diese Studenten war. Also allein der Fakt, dass sie sie gelassen haben, hat die Regierung schon verantwortlich gemacht. Und ja, es gibt da ganz, ganz softe Abstufungen, je nachdem, was dann überhaupt da passiert ist. Deswegen denke ich, dass das International Space Law zum Beispiel sehr anwendbar wäre für sowas.
Also es gab noch so ein paar andere Vorschläge, die ich noch nicht gehört habe. Eine davon war, Netzwerkmarkierungen für sowas zum Beispiel als Äquivalent von krankenhäusern zu finden. Also sowas wie das Rote Kreuz auf dem Dach vom krankenhaus, was halt in Kriegszonen verwendet wird. Ob man nicht, keine Ahnung, entweder......
ins DNS schreiben, diese IP ist diplomatisch, gibt es diplomatische Qualität.
Oder halten... Na ja, ich meine, da würde es ja zum Beispiel Methoden für geben, wenn man zum Beispiel ein Adress Space nimmt oder sowas.
Na ja, klar.
Dass man sagt, okay, in diesem Adress Space gibt es international zu grauen nur krankenhäuser, whatever. Also jedenfalls schutzwürdige Infrastruktur. Und wer darin rumwildert, wird halt irgendwie sofort geniugt.
Ja gut, aber weißt du, dann hast du wieder irgendwie einen ausschnitt, der unter besonderen Schutz gestellt wurde. Und so das zum Beispiel das Umweltrecht, also das internationale Umweltrecht, fängt mit den Worten an, pollution does not respect borders or political areas oder sowas. Also da wird von vornherein gesagt, es ist uns klar, dass man das nicht kontrollieren kann. Und so ein souveräner Staat ist halt einfach mal verdammt nochmal dafür verantwortlich, dass von seinem Boden aus keine pollution ausgeht.
Klar, aber die Frage ist ja trotzdem, wenn man sagt, es gibt ja ein gutes Argument dafür, ein gutes Argument dagegen, wenn man sagt, man macht zum Beispiel so eine Rot-Kreuz-Markierung, also nur mal angenommen, dann hast du natürlich zwei Effekte. Der eine Effekt ist, dass man...
Dass die krankenhäuser keine Verteidigung mehr bauen, weil sie sich für sich halten.
Oder dass man sagt, okay, zumindest in diesem Bereich stellt man halt noch ein minimunus funktionieren von Infrastruktur sicher. Auf der anderen Seite gibt sich dann natürlich der Effekt, aha, okay, wenn alle sichere Infrastruktur da drin ist, dann können wir den Rest der Problemlos platt machen, weil der ist ja dann offensichtlich nicht kritisch, wenn er nicht da drin ist. So ist er dann sozusagen.
Das ist alle so schön vernetzt.
Eigentlich nur nebeneffekte, die schlecht sind.
Das funktioniert in unserer heutigen vernetzten Welt so einfach nicht mehr. Also ich meine, wenn du das krankenhaus nicht angreifst, aber das Wasserwerk daneben platt machst und das Umspannwerk auch, dann was sollen die denn in dem krankenhaus machen?
Also wir sehen halt irgendwie die Frage, wie man so einen Cyberwarfare-Treaty bauen könnte. Die wird uns wohl noch eine ganze Weile beschäftigen. Zumal auch gerade zumindest die Amis oder so und auch die anderen großen Player nicht so richtig viel Interesse daran haben. Mit ausnahme interessanterweise wohl der russen.
Und der Chinesen. Na die russen und die Chinesen haben das zusammen gemacht. Die haben letztes Jahr einen Resolutionsvorschlag bei der UN eingebracht. Also die russen haben ihn eingebracht, die Chinesen haben ihn unterstützt. Indem sie so ein paar Punkte gefordert haben. Also man man dürfe nicht irgendwie die Netze eines anderen Landes angreifen, auch nicht mit irregulären Truppen. Man dürfe keine Wirtschaftsspionage darüber betreiben. Also kurz zusammengefasst, das was man den Chinesen und den russen allgemein so zuschreibt, haben sie sozusagen in einem großen Katalog verbieten wollen. Die Amis und die Briten waren dagegen. Effekt ist nämlich, nehmen wir mal an, die russen und die Chinesen tun das heim, heutzutage. Die haben nicht so was wie ein parlamentarische Kontrollinstanz. Die Briten und die Amis haben zumindest zum Teil immer noch irgendwie so parlamentarische Kontrolle dahinter. Das heißt, die sitzen gerade händeringend da und hätten gerne dieselbe Freiheit wie die russen und die Chinesen. Und die russen und die Chinesen denken sich ja, wir machen das ja also angenommen, wir machen das ja eh gerade schon. Wenn wir das jetzt irgendwie bei der UN einbringen, dann würden sich die Amis sozusagen den aufsteigenden Ast, wo sie gerade hin wollen, selber absägen. Deswegen machen die das nicht. Also das ist der ganze Hintergrund dabei. Es ist eigentlich bei den Chinesen, wenn die dann darüber Vorträge halten, fällt das auch sehr auf, das ist eigentlich irgendwie einen dicken Mittelfinger zeigen. Also die Vorträge der Chinesen gehen normalerweise so in die Richtung, wir haben nur 550 Millionen Internetanschlüsse, das heißt, wir haben eigentlich gar nicht die Kapazität, das zu machen, was ihr uns alle vorwerft. Wir sind noch ein Entwicklungsland und wir sind keine Weltmacht.
Verstehe, wir sind zu klein, wir armen.
Genau.
Also wenn ich klein höre, denke ich auch sofort an China.
Das ist jetzt was, was wir einführen, logischerweise. Und so. Dann sind wir, glaube ich, am Ende angelangt. Oder hast du noch einen Aspekt, den du noch unbedingt mit unterbringen wolltest?
Ich? Nein.
Gut. Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank fürs Hiersein.
Gerne.
Wenn ihr wollt, da ist so ein Kletterbutton an der Seite, auf den ihr draufdrucken könnt. Wir hoffen, dieses Mal hält unsere Infrastruktur ein bisschen besser als beim letzten Mal und beim vorletzten Mal. Und dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.